What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Inst. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Welcome back to our second drink of a Benihana Christmas. We had two amazing perspectives
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？那就是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到您家门口的、在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。即使您在儿童戏水池里，也能订购到这样一块大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足您。下载Instacart应用程序，享受前三单0配送费优惠。服务费、除外条款和条款适用。Instacart，为您提供超值配送的杂货服务。欢迎回到我们《Benihana圣诞节》特辑的第二杯饮品时间。我们在这集节目中
on this episode. Yes. Rashida Jones joins us to talk about this episode and her time on The Office. And writer Jen Salata answered fan questions. Well, I'll kick us off with this fan mail flurry. Angela, in our breakdown, you shared about going to Belize with Rashida to help with ocean preservation, and you talked about how many boats the two of you were on together. So many boats. Yes. You and I both comment that you and I have never been on a boat together.
有两个非常棒的视角。是的。拉什达·琼斯（Rashida Jones）加入我们，聊了聊这一集以及她在《办公室》的时光。编剧简·萨拉塔（Jen Salata）也回答了粉丝的问题。好吧，我先从这堆粉丝来信开始。安吉拉，在我们的解析中，你分享了和拉什达一起去伯利兹帮助海洋保护的事情，还谈到了你们俩一起坐过多少次船。好多船啊。是的。你和我都在评论说，我们俩从来没有一起坐过船。
Yeah. Very confidently, we say this. Very confidently. Yeah. I'm like, yeah, Jenna, you and I have never been on a boat together. Very confidently. Very confidently. Yeah, I'm like, yeah, Jenna, you and I have never been on a boat. And you're like, we never have. Well, Lady Bailey Kay and many others wrote in to say that we were, in fact, on a boat together for about a week in the Boo's Cruise episode. It made me laugh. I know. Why didn't we think of that? I don't know. I don't know. We had just broken it down.
是的。我们非常自信地说。非常自信。是的，我就说，是啊，珍娜，你和我从来没一起坐过船。非常自信。非常自信。是的，我就说，是啊，珍娜，你和我从来没坐过船。然后你说，我们确实没坐过。好吧，贝利·凯女士（Lady Bailey Kay）和其他许多人写信说，事实上，我们在《Boo's Cruise》那一集中一起坐过大约一周的船。这让我笑了。我知道。我们怎么没想到呢？我不知道。我不知道。我们刚刚才解析完那一集。
I know. We also talked broken it down. I know. We also talked about how many deleted scenes there are for this episode. I wanted to share with you that many of them made it into the Peacock superfan version. That version is actually 47 minutes long. Wow. I know.
我知道。我们还谈到了这一集有多少删减片段。我想告诉你们，其中许多片段被收录进了Peacock的超级粉丝版本中。那个版本实际上有47分钟长。哇。我知道。
That is six more minutes of footage added to an already pretty big episode. But Angela, you said that you found something new on the DVD box set that you were all excited about. Guys, she left me a message about the DVD box set. This lady loves to find things. I also couldn't believe I had missed it. I was like, how did I miss this?
那是在原本就很长的一集里又增加了六分钟的镜头。但是安吉拉，你说你在DVD套装里发现了一些让你很兴奋的新东西。伙计们，她给我留了一条关于DVD套装的留言。这位女士太喜欢发现新东西了。我也无法相信我竟然错过了它。我当时想，我怎么会错过这个？
So this disc has a ton of extras. It's got interviews. There was a make your own promo for the office contest where fans could send in their promos. It's disc two of season three, for those of you who have the box set, but it also has a lot of extra footage and scenes that we filmed that were never part of any episodes
所以这张光盘里有大量的花絮。它有采访。还有一个“为《办公室》制作你自己的宣传片”的比赛，粉丝们可以寄来他们的宣传片。对于那些有套装的人来说，这是第三季的第二张光盘，但它还包含了很多我们拍摄的、从未在任何播出剧集中出现的额外镜头和场景。
that aired. Here's a list of bonus content. Number one, Kevin Cook's stuff in The Office. Wow. I know. Number two, a six minute excerpt of scenes. They're like these little vignettes that we filmed for the 2006 NBC primetime preview.
这是一份奖励内容列表。第一，凯文在《办公室》里的烹饪片段。哇。我知道。第二，六分钟的场景节选。它们就像是我们为2006年NBC黄金时段预告片拍摄的小短片。
I guess the cast of The Office hosted it and they played these before we came on stage maybe. I watched them, I had no memory of them. This is so weird. I know. Then there are these things called came on stage maybe. I watched them, I had no memory of them. This is so weird. I know. Then there are these things called Toby wraparounds. They're like these little interstitials of Toby saying stuff.
我想可能是《办公室》的演员们主持了它，也许在我们上台之前播放了这些片段。我看了它们，但我一点记忆都没有。这太奇怪了。我知道。然后还有一些叫做“托比环绕片段”（Toby wraparounds）的东西。它们就像是托比说一些话的小插曲。
And a Dwight Schrute music video. We did a lot of things. I know. In addition to shoot the show. And this doesn't even include, there's some interviews and the promo contest and stuff. So this disc is stacked with bonus content. I thought maybe as we do these second drinks, I will share some of these little things along
还有一个德怀特·舒鲁特（Dwight Schrute）的音乐录影带。我们做了很多事情。我知道。除了拍摄剧集之外。而且这甚至还不包括一些采访、宣传比赛之类的东西。所以这张光盘里塞满了奖励内容。我想也许在我们喝这些“第二杯”的时候，我可以沿途分享一些这些小东西。
the way. Okay. But for today, I think we should hear a few of the Toby wraparounds. There's a lot, but here's just a few. Hi, I'm Toby Flenderson. Or, speak up. Hi, I'm Toby Flenderson. Or as Michael refers to me, worthless.
好的。但今天，我觉得我们应该听听几个托比的环绕片段。有很多，但这只是其中几个。嗨，我是托比·弗伦德森（Toby Flenderson）。或者，大声点。嗨，我是托比·弗伦德森。或者正如迈克尔所称呼我的，废物。
Or everything that's wrong with the paper industry. Or the devil's butthole. Or the mayor of Creepsville. Or Gargamel. Or human fart. I prefer Toby. This feels loud. Am I being too loud? HR nightmares here at Dunham Mifflin.
或者造纸业中所有错误的总和。或者魔鬼的肛门。或者怪胎镇的镇长。或者格格巫（Gargamel）。或者人类屁。我更喜欢托比。这感觉太吵了。我声音太大了吗？邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的人力资源噩梦。
I don't know if I call them that. You know, nightmare implies it's something you wake up from. You know, this is more of an unrelenting daymare. Kind of this... never-ending dreamscape of horror. Ah, human resources, it's not just a job, it's a way of life. But I wish it was just a job.
我不知道我是否会称它们为噩梦。你知道，噩梦意味着那是你会从中醒来的东西。你知道，这更像是一场无情的“日梦”。有点像……永无止境的恐怖梦境。啊，人力资源，这不仅仅是一份工作，这是一种生活方式。但我希望它只是一份工作。
What did we use those for? We don't know. We don't know. Well, Lady, I don't know if you remember, but you promised to play some more of the fakey PSAs. Yes, I do. You still owe us that. Yeah, I have a lot that I can sprinkle in. All right, but you promised to play some more of the fakey PSAs. Yes, I do. You still owe us that. Yeah, I have a lot that I can sprinkle in.
我们用那些来做什么？我们不知道。我们不知道。好吧，女士，我不知道你是否还记得，但你答应过要播放更多那些虚假的公益广告（PSA）。是的，我记得。你还欠我们那个呢。是的，我有很多可以穿插进去。好吧，但你答应过要播放更多那些虚假的公益广告。是的，我记得。你还欠我们那个呢。是的，我有很多可以穿插进去。
All right. Well, I love it. And now everyone, here is our breakdown of a Benny Hauna Christmas. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The
好吧。我喜欢。现在大家，这是我们对《Benihana圣诞节》的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”。圣诞快乐，圣诞快乐，《办公室》又迎来圣诞节了。好吧，有人打扮得非常有节日气氛。没错！这是《Benihana圣诞节》！好吧，我想安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）会让你知道这是“胡桃夹子圣诞节”。哦，哇。哦，哇，你已经开始那样说了。我是，女士。我在这里。派对策划委员会已经到了。
Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the Office Ladies. Merry Merry Christmas, Merry Merry Christmas, it's Christmas on the office again. Well someone showed up very festive. That's right! It's a Benny Hauna Christmas! Well, I think Angela Martin would let you know it's a Nutcracker Christmas. Oh, wow. Oh, wow, you're already going there. I am, lady. I am here. The party planning committee has arrived.
好吧，我们会谈谈那个。伙计们，这是第三季第10集，由简·萨拉塔编剧，哈罗德·雷米斯（Harold Ramis）导演，《Benihana圣诞节》。这是一集长达一小时的剧集。是的，所以系好安全带。这将是《办公室女士》的超大号剧集。我们有一些令人兴奋的消息。本周我们有两位特别嘉宾，拉什达·琼斯和编剧简·萨拉塔。太有趣了。这两位女士都将加入我们
Well, we'll talk about that. Guys, this is season three, episode 10, written by Jen Salata, directed by Harold Ramis, a Benihana Christmas. And this is an hour-long episode. Yeah, so buckle in. It's gonna be a super-sized episode of Office Ladies. And we have some exciting news. We have two special guests this week, Rashida Jones and writer Jen Salata. So much fun. And both of these ladies will be joining us
在节目中接受采访。好吧，珍娜，给我们做一个总结怎么样？好的。邓德·米夫林迎来了圣诞节。卡罗尔（Carol）在圣诞派对当天和迈克尔分手了，因为迈克尔把自己的照片PS到了她家人的圣诞贺卡上。他把自己的脸换成了她前夫在家庭滑雪旅行中的脸，并寄给了大家。是的。
for interviews during the episode. Well, Jenna, how about giving us a summary? Okay. It is Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Carol breaks up with Michael the day of the Christmas party after Michael photoshops himself under her family Christmas card. He put his face on her ex-husband's face from a family ski trip and sent it out to people. Yeah.
哦，迈克尔。好吧，安迪建议他和一些伙计带迈克尔去Benihana餐厅让他振作起来。与此同时，安吉拉把凯伦（Karen）踢出了派对策划委员会。所以帕姆（Pam）和凯伦联手成立了委员会来策划派对。我们要有两场针锋相对的节日派对了。不，她本该有更好的主意。哦，天哪。你今天真是为了赢而不择手段啊，安吉。
Oh, Michael. Well, Andy suggests he and some of the guys take Michael to Benihana to cheer him up. Meanwhile, Angela kicks Karen out of the party planning committee. So Pam and Karen band together and start the committee to plan parties. We're going to have some dueling holiday parties. No, she should have had better ideas. Oh, boy. You are in it to win it today, Angie.
我是来玩的。我是来玩的。好吧，后来，迈克尔和伙计们带着约会对象从Benihana回来，正好赶上两场派对合并，最后大家都在卡拉OK里尽情歌唱。好的，第一个速记事实。哈罗德·雷米斯。哈罗德·雷米斯。我的意思是，珍娜，我的整个童年都是他的电影。传奇。我当时又激动、又紧张、又兴奋能和他一起工作。我的意思是，《肉丸子》（Meatballs）、《疯狂高尔夫》（Caddyshack）、《捉鬼敢死队》（Ghostbusters）、
I came to play. I came to play. Well, later, Michael and the boys come back from Benihana with dates just in time for the two parties to merge, and we end with everyone singing their hearts out to karaoke. All right, fast fact number one. Harold Ramis. Harold Ramis. I mean, Jenna, my whole childhood were his movies. Legend. I was so giddy, nervous, excited to work with him. I mean, meatballs, Caddyshack, Ghostbusters,
《捉鬼敢死队2》、《土拨鼠之日》（Groundhog Day），天哪。《条纹》（Stripes）。《条纹》，哦天哪，是的，《条纹》。哦，还有安吉拉，他是在芝加哥的“第二城”（Second City）起家的。是的！他就是那么有才华。伙计们，他也是一位非常出色的编剧。他是一位编剧、演员、导演。他简直就是喜剧传奇，我当时敬畏不已。
Ghostbusters 2, Groundhog Day for flippin' sake. Stripes. Stripes, oh my God, yes, stripes. Oh, also Angela, he got his start at Chicago's Second City. Yes! He's just, like, so talented. He's such a great writer as well, you guys. He's a writer, actor, director. He was just a comic legend, and I was in awe.
好吧，你知道，他在2014年去世了。坦白说，我简直不敢相信我能和他一起工作。我知道。哈罗德·雷米斯简直就是一个泰迪熊般的人。他让你感到非常舒适，和他聊天非常有趣。我对他有很多美好的回忆。显然，我们在这一集中做了很多会议室场景。我在会议室里待了相当长的时间，对吧？因为我的派对和凯伦与帕姆的派对。是的。哈罗德和我都在会议室里
Well, you know, he passed away in 2014. I just can't believe that I got to work with him, frankly. I know. Harold Ramis was just a teddy bear of a human. He just made you feel so comfortable, and he was so fun to talk to. And I have some great memories of him. We did a lot of conference room scenes, obviously, in this episode. I was in the conference room quite a bit, right? Because my party versus Karen's and Pam's party. Yeah. And Harold was in the conference room with me
我们只是在聊天。他讲了一个很棒的故事，说当孩子们去他家讨糖果时，他住在伊利诺伊州，他会穿上《捉鬼敢死队》的制服，穿着那身制服去开门。是的，他每年都这样做。我觉得这太令人愉快了。这是最甜蜜的故事。
and we were just chatting. And he told this great story about how when kids would come trick or treating to his house, he lived in Illinois, he would put on the Ghostbusters uniform and answer the door in his Ghostbusters uniform. Yeah, he did that every year. I thought that was so delightful. It was the sweetest story.
好的，让我们进入第二个速记事实，我称之为“客串明星解析”。好的。我们要解析我们所有的客串明星，Benihana的女服务员。餐厅里的主要女服务员辛迪（Cindy）由布列塔尼·石桥（Brittany Ishibashi）饰演，你可能在《离家童盟》（Runaways）中认出她。她饰演了蒂娜（Tina），还在《天堂执法者》（Hawaii Five-0）和《同妻俱乐部》（Grace and Frankie）中担任常驻角色。但关于布列塔尼和我，有一件非常有趣的事情。什么？奇怪的是，布列塔尼和我都在电视剧《Off Center》和《Mismatch》中客串过，但我们不在同一集。所以《办公室》是她和我
All right, let's move into Fast Fact number two, which I'm calling Guest Star Breakdown. Okay. We got to break down all of our guest stars, the Benihana waitresses. The main waitress in the restaurant, Cindy, is played by Brittany Ishibashi, who you might recognize from Runaways. She starred as Tina, as well as recurring roles on Hawaii Five-0 and Grace and Frankie. But here is something very interesting about Brittany and me. What? Okay, weirdly, both Brittany and I have had guest appearances on the TV shows Off Center and Mismatch, but we were not in the same episode. So The Office was the third project that she and I have
都参与的第三个项目，但我们从未共享过一个场景，也从未见过面。这太疯狂了。我们的生活似乎一直在交集。布列塔尼，我有一天会见到你吗？你们正走在最终在同一时间、同一天、同一个场景中参与同一个项目的轨道上。所以，安吉拉，还有两位客串女服务员。这些是迈克尔和安迪
both been in, but we've never shared a scene and we've never met. That's crazy. Our lives have sort of been intersecting. Brittany, am I gonna meet you one day? You're on track to finally be in a project together at the same time on the same day, in the same scene. So, Angela, there are two more guest star waitresses. These are the waitresses that Michael and Andy
带回派对的女服务员。首先是艾米（Amy），由Kat On饰演，她做了大量的素描喜剧、单口相声、《Funny or Die》。然后是迈克尔的女朋友尼基（Nikki），由Kulop V. Lysak饰演。好的，我和Kulop在《奥兰多娇妻》（Hot Wives of Orlando）中合作过。那是Hulu上的一部剧。它是对《比弗利娇妻》（Real Housewives）非常有趣的恶搞，她在里面表现得很棒。她在很多事情上都很棒，但做那个真的很有趣。好吧，女士，你知道我喜欢那个。我知道。
bring back to the party. So, first there is Amy, who is played by Kat On, and she's done just a ton of sketch comedy, stand up, funny or die. And then there is Michael's girlfriend, Nikki, who is played by Kulop V. Lysak. Okay, I worked with Kulop on Hot Wives of Orlando. It was the show on Hulu. It's a really funny spook of the Real Housewives and she was great in it. She's great in a lot of things, but that was a lot of fun to do. Well, Lady, you know I loved that. I know.
好的。第三个速记事实。我从“肯托百科”（Kentopedia）那里得到了关于Benihana拍摄地点的内幕，因为我们收到了很多粉丝关于它的问题。我想问那个，因为我一直在想那是不是恩西诺（Encino）的那家Benihana。确实是。我去过那家Benihana，当我重温这一集时，你走进餐厅的方式，你知道，
Okay. Fast fact number three. I got the scoop from Kentopedia on the Benihana location, because we got a lot of fan questions about it. I wanted to ask about that, because I was wondering if it's the Benihana's in Encino. It sure is. I have been to that Benihana's, and when I was rewatching this, the way you walk into the restaurant, you know,
是一样的。我当时想，是啊，得了吧，那就是加州恩西诺的Benihana。好吧，女士，我们收到了一些粉丝的问题，来自阿什利·希尔德雷斯（Ashley Hildreth）、瑞秋·马蒂诺（Rachel Martino）、汉娜·霍尔特曼（Hannah Holtman）、马利亚·霍尔布鲁克（Malia Holbrook）、阿比盖尔·赫斯（Abigail Hess）、鲁平德·戈塞尔（Rupinder Gossel）以及许多其他人，他们都问，餐厅场景是在真正的餐厅拍摄的吗？它必须关闭多久？Benihana的厨师是真正的Benihana厨师吗？还是演员？
it's the same. And I was like, yeah, come on, that's Benihana's in Encino, California. Well, lady, we got some fan questions from Ashley Hildreth, Rachel Martino, Hannah Holtman, Malia Holbrook, Abigail Hess, Rupinder Gossel, and many others, all asked, were the restaurant scenes filmed at an actual restaurant? How long did it have to be shut down? And is the chef at Benihana an actual Benihana chef? Or was it an actor?
我要说是的，因为他用那把刀太厉害了。是的。我们从那里开始。那是真正的厨师。我们雇佣了恩西诺Benihana所有的厨师和所有的服务人员在这一集中表演。我们还雇佣了78名背景演员来扮演食客。我们关闭了它整整一天。我们租下了整个地方
I'm going to say yes, because he was too good with that knife. Yes. We will start there. It was a real chef. We hired all of the chefs and all of the wait staff of the Encino Benihana to perform in the episode. And we also hired 78 background actors to play diners. We shut it down for a whole day. We rented out the entire place
拍摄这些场景大约花了12个小时。这提醒我，我们的预算更充足了，因为过去我们什么时候能进去说，我们要包下整个地方。我的意思是，即使是Chili's也是那种倒闭了、封上木板的。是的，没错。餐厅。但这是一家实际上非常成功、总是挤满人的餐厅。我们让他们停业了一天。哇哦。好吧，我深入研究了Benihana。我现在想给你们讲讲历史
and it took about 12 hours to shoot those scenes. This is reminding me that we had a bigger budget because when in the past could we go in and be like, we'll take the whole place. I mean, even Chili's was like an out of business boarded up. Yes, that's right. Restaurant. But this was like an actually like very successful restaurant that was always full of people. And we closed them down for a day. Wowzies. Well, and I did a deep dive on Benihana. And I'd like to give you now the history
关于Benihana餐厅。好吧，我没预料到这一点，所以我准备好了。这太迷人了。这是来自Benihana网站的内容，这是他们对Benihana餐厅历史描述的第一行。我要引用它，因为它太棒了。引用，像任何好故事一样，
of Benihana, the restaurant. Well, I didn't see that coming, so I'm ready. It's fascinating. This is from the Benihana website, and this is the first line from their description of the history of the Benihana website, and this is the first line from their description of the history of the Benihana restaurant. I'm gonna quote it, because it is fantastic. Quote, like any good story,
Benihana的历史始于一位武士的后裔和一家小小的东京咖啡店。你感兴趣了吗？我被迷住了。好的。这太神奇了。事情是这样的。东京有一对夫妇，Yunosuke和Katsu。
the history of Benihana begins with the descendant of a samurai warrior and a small Tokyo coffee shop. Are you intrigued? I'm riveted. Okay. It's amazing. So this is what happened. So there's a couple in Tokyo, Yunosuke and Katsu.
他们开了一家咖啡店。为了让自己与众不同，Yunosuke会骑自行车超过20英里去买真正的糖，用来在店里配咖啡。这个小细节使这家店大获成功。他们咖啡店的名字叫Benihana。好的。快进到多年后，这对夫妇的儿子Rocky怀揣着开餐厅的梦想搬到了美国。
They started a coffee shop. And in order to set themselves apart, Yunosuke would bike over 20 miles to get real sugar to serve with the coffee in his shop. And this little detail caused the shop to be a huge success. The name of their coffee shop was Benihana. All right. Cut to years later, the couple's son, Rocky, moves to the United States with dreams of opening a restaurant.
他先去夜校学习餐厅管理，白天在哈莱姆区的街头卖冰淇淋。但他做了什么呢？他在冰淇淋里插了一把小小的日本鸡尾酒伞，这真的让它与众不同，最终他赚了1万美元，他用这笔钱开了他的第一家Benihana餐厅，并以他父母在东京的咖啡店命名。好吧，那太可爱了。而且，我对任何带有小伞的东西都没有抵抗力。给我吧。任何带有小伞的饮料尝起来都更好。确实如此。哦，是的。我的意思是，这是一个事实。我可能保存了一些，比如在特殊场合用的，它们现在就在我的厨房里。
He starts by going to night school to study restaurant management, and during the day, he sold ice cream on the streets of Harlem. But here's what he did. He put a little Japanese cocktail umbrella into the ice cream, and this really set it apart and eventually he earned $10,000, which he used to open his first Benny Hanna restaurant, naming it after his parents' coffee shop in Tokyo. Well, that was adorable. Also, I'm a sucker for anything with a tiny umbrella in it. Give it to me. Any drink with a tiny umbrella tastes better. It really does. Oh, yeah. I mean, that's a fact. I might have saved a few of those, like from special occasions, and they're in my kitchen.
我不怀疑。那非常像你。我知道。我丈夫说，我们还需要这些吗？我的意思是，小棍子都断了。我说，不，别扔掉。好的，故事还有后续。好的，他的第一家店，在西56街，和今天的一模一样。
I don't doubt it. That is very you. I know. My husband's like, do we still need these? I mean, the little stick is broken. I'm like, no, don't throw it away. Okay, so there's more to the story. Okay, his first shop, which was on West 56th Street, it was exactly like how it is today.
他的愿景是让铁板烧烤架设置在顾客面前，厨师们做所有的刀工。但起初很挣扎。直到开业六个月后，一位著名的美食评论家进来并给了这家餐厅极好的评价，餐厅得到了提振。这是我最喜欢的部分。我能告诉你那位美食评论家的名字吗？这位著名的美食评论家，
His vision was to have the tempenyaki grills set up in front of the customers with the chefs doing all the knife work. But it was struggling at first. Until six months after they opened, the restaurant got a boost when a famous food critic came in and gave the restaurant a fabulous review. Here's my favorite part of that. Can I tell you the name of the food critic? This famous food critic,
就像你希望这个人来你的餐厅一样。你准备好了吗？谁？克莱门汀·帕德尔福德（Clementine Paddleford）。哦，天哪。她听起来像玛丽·波平斯（Mary Poppins）电影里的虚构角色。她听起来像一个即兴表演游戏
like you wanted this person to come to your restaurant. Are you ready? Who? Clementine Paddleford. Oh my God. She sounds like a made up character in a Mary Poppins movie. She sounds like an improv game
我做即兴表演时常玩的那种。嘿伙计们，来吧，我们要演克莱门汀·帕德尔福德。我们开始吧。对吧？我当时想，发生了什么？我们在迪士尼电影里吗？我想要那个，等等，等等，等等。我现在有太多想用这个名字的方法了。
that I used to do when I did improv. Hey guys, come on, we're gonna do Clementine Padaford. Let's do it. Right? I was like, what is happening? We're in a Disney film. I want that, wait, wait, wait. There's just so many ways I wanna use that name now.
比如我想让它成为一种鸡尾酒。请给我来一杯克莱门汀·帕德尔福德。它配有一把伞。谢谢克莱门汀给Benihana的好评，因为这家餐厅大获成功。现在在美国、加勒比海地区以及中南美洲有超过70家Benihana餐厅。怎么样？
Like I want it to be a cocktail. I'll take a Clementine Padaford, please. It comes with an umbrella. And thank you Clementine for giving Benihana a rave review because the restaurant became a huge success. And there are now over 70 Benihana restaurants in the United States, Caribbean, and Central and South America. How about that?
那真的很棒。你知道吗？如果你的名字叫克莱门汀·帕德尔福德，你就是纽约市最好的美食评论家。我的意思是，是的，我脑海中清晰地浮现出这个女人和她挑剔的饮食习惯。是的。哦，我需要看看她长什么样。我只能想象她用非常小的餐具吃饭，比如一把小叉子，对吧。嗯哼。为什么？为什么会这样？
That is a really good one. And you know what? If your name is Clementine Paddleford, you are the best food critic in New York City. I mean, yes, I have a clear picture of this woman and her discerning food eating. Yeah. Oh, I need to see what she looks like. I only imagine her eating with like very tiny cutlery, like a tiny fork in a right. Mm hmm. Why? Why is that?
好的，女士。谢谢你纵容我深入研究Benihana和克莱门汀·帕德尔福德。你在开玩笑吗？我喜欢它。我的生活中需要更多克莱门汀·帕德尔福德。我也是。我也是。但听着，我们现在应该进入我们的第一次采访吗？
All right, lady. Thank you for indulging my deep dive on Benny Hanna and Clementine Paddleford. Are you kidding? I loved it. I need more Clementine Paddleford in my life. Same. Same. But listen, should we move on now to our first interview?
是的。好的，伙计们。我们在这一集中和拉什达·琼斯有一个非常有趣的故事情节，关于两场针锋相对的圣诞派对，拍摄起来真是太棒了。我们迫不及待地想和她重聚并聊聊这一切。所以让我们开始吧。萨姆，播放拉什达的采访。我很高兴见到你的脸。我知道，我也是。这太好了。我不认为我们三个人，好吧，我们不在同一个地方，但我们已经像十年一样一直在互相交谈了。
Yes. Okay, guys. We had such a fun storyline with Rashida Jones in this episode with the whole dueling Christmas parties and it was such a blast to shoot. We couldn't wait to reunite with her and talk all about it. So let's get to it. Sam, run the interview with Rashida. I'm so happy to see your face. I know me too. This is so nice. I don't think the three of us have been, well, we're not in the same place, but we have been all talking to each other for like a decade.
哦，是的。都在同一个地方。是的。我想你是对的。这让我有点难过。这太疯狂了。伊莎贝尔（Isabel）前几天问了我一个非常随机的问题。她说，妈妈，你和你的哪些朋友一起坐过船？
Oh, yeah. All in the same one place. Yeah. I think you're right. That makes me a little sad. It's crazy. Isabel asked me a really random question the other day. She was like, mom, who of your friends have you been on a boat with?
我说，嗯，我的意思是拉什达和我去参加了一个海洋保护之旅，为了大洋洲（Oceania），所以我们坐了很多船。我们有很多，我的意思是，我们几乎每天都在船上。那是真的。我们那是真的。我们一直在计算坐了多少次船，我说，嗯，严格来说可能不是同一艘船，但每天都坐船。那天我们潜水的那一次，那里有，
And I was like, well, I mean Rashida and I went on an ocean conservation trip for Oceania So we were on a lot of boats We had a lot I mean we were like on a boat almost every day. That's true. We that's true He's so we were we were like clocking how many boats and I'm like, well, technically maybe same boat but a boat every day. That one dive that we took that day where there was like,
就像海洋的入门课。有鲨鱼、鳗鱼和海龟。那真是太酷了。那是最酷的。我知道。啊，那太棒了。我怀念这一切。我知道。但是，那太棒了。我怀念这一切。我知道。
it was like the 101 of the ocean. It was like sharks and eels and turtles. It was just the coolest. It was the coolest. I know. Ah, that was great. I miss all of that. I know. But, that was great. I miss all of that. I know.
但是是的，我只是觉得这就像你孩子问你的那种问题。然后她说，等等，你从来没和珍娜一起坐过船？我说，不，珍娜。你们从来没坐过船吗？我们从来没坐过船。我们有一些冒险经历，珍娜。好吧，你得让它发生。你可能得像在船上录制你的播客一样。
But yeah, I just thought it was just like one of those questions your kid asked you. And then she's like, wait, you've never been on a boat with Jenna? I was like, no, Jenna. Have you guys never been on a boat? We've never been on a boat. We've got some adventures, Jenna. Well, you got it. You got to make that happen. You might have to do like a like a recording of your podcast on a boat.
哦，天哪，拉什达，看看我们现在的设置。想象一下，听起来不错，对吧？是的。为了未来？是的。有一天我们会一起划船和录播客。是的。哦，天哪，我喜欢。好吧，我们怎么感谢你都不为过。我们很高兴你能来。
Oh dear Lord, Rashida, look at our setup right now. Doesn't it sound good to imagine though? Yes. For the future? Yes. One day we'll be boating and podcasting together. Yeah. Oh God, I love it. Well, we can't thank you enough for being here. We're so thrilled to have you.
我很高兴能来。好吧，拉什达，我们总是问嘉宾的一个问题是，你是怎么加入《办公室》的？我试镜了很多很多次。在加入剧组之前，我在社交场合认识一些人。我和迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）是大学同学。大一的时候我们一起演过一部戏。哦，天哪。哦，那真是个极品。我很想看看迈克·舒尔在大学里是什么样子。他还是老样子。
I'm so happy to be here. Well, Rashida, one question we always ask our guests is how did you come to be on the office? I auditioned many, many times. I knew people socially before I joined the cast. And I went to college with Mike Schur. We were in a play together freshman year. Oh man. Oh, it was a doozy. I would love to see what Mike Schur was like in college. He was the same.
他还是老样子？是的，他留着软塌塌的头发。我的意思是，他稍微少一点，我记得在我们二十多岁的时候，他第一次穿了一件花哨的衬衫，我取笑了他很长一段时间。所以他就像没有经过任何社交化的迈克，你知道。我们一起演了一部非常糟糕的闹剧。
He was the same? Yeah, he was like floppy haired. I mean, he was a little less, I remember like in our twenties, he got like a fancy shirt for the first time and making fun of him for a really long time. So he was like Mike without like, any sort of like socialization, you know. And we were in a like really bad farce together.
是的，我们很快成了朋友，一起上了很多课。总之，我认识迈克，我开始了解美国版《办公室》，因为他从纽约搬过来，说，我在洛杉矶找了份工作，我要去写美国版《办公室》。我当时真的很生他的气，我想很多人也是，因为我们当时想，你怎么能对英国版《办公室》做这种事，那可是我最喜欢的剧？你怎么敢尝试？是的。然后它在很多方面成了它自己的东西，甚至更好，很棒。
And yeah, we became fast friends and we took a lot of classes together. And anyway, so I knew Mike, and I came to know about the US office because he moved from New York and said, I got a job in LA and I'm going to write the US office. I was really mad at him, as I think a lot of people were, because we were like, how could you do that to the UK office, my favorite show? How could you even try? Yeah. Then it was in a lot of ways its own thing and even better and great.
我相信这对你们所有人来说都是一座大山。哦，是的。我的第一反应是，不，不，不，不，不。它是完美的。它是完美的。对，对。然后当然，当我知道是格雷格（Greg）和那些聪明人
It was a big mountain, I'm sure, for you all to climb. Oh yeah. My first reaction was like, no, no, no, no, no. It's perfect. It's perfect. Right, right. And then of course I was like so thrilled, you know, when it was like Greg and such smart people
在编剧室里时，我非常激动。你们有幸扮演没有英国对应角色的角色。就像我一直担心的，哦不，我不希望人们认为我从露西·戴维斯（Lucy Davis）那里偷了我的表演。对。但我看过她的表演，我相信它渗透进来了。怎么可能不呢？
in the writer's room. You guys had the benefit of playing characters that didn't have a British counterpart. Like I was always worried, oh no, I don't want people to think that I stole my performance from Lucy Davis. Right. But I had seen her performance, and I'm sure it seeped in. How could it not?
而且，试播集里的台词也是一样的。对。但你们在影响你们的角色方面发挥了很大的作用，我想。这对你来说是真的吗，拉什达？安吉拉之前谈到过这一点。记得吗，英国版《办公室》里出现了一个三角恋的第三点。蒂姆（Tim）有一个追求者，但对那个可能威胁到那段关系的人的刻画完全不同。
And also, the lines were the same in the pilot. Right. But you guys had a big part, I think, of getting to influence your characters. Is that true on your part, Rashida? Angel's kind of talked about that before. There was some, remember there was some third point in a triangle that showed up in the UK office. There was like a love interest for Tim that came up, but a completely different like characterization of somebody who, you know, who who would be a threat to that relationship.
为了结束那个观点，只是想说我试镜了很多很多次。我记得当时有一种独特的感觉，珍娜，当我们坐在一个房间里一起读台词，然后即兴发挥了一点，一切突然都说得通了。你知道，就像，它是一个如此酷的对应物。就像，它让我觉得，哦，我真的，
To end that other point, just to say that I auditioned many, many, many times, and I remember having a distinct feeling then when I got to the point, Jenna, where you and I sat in a room and read lines together, and then got to improv a little bit, everything just made sense all of a sudden. You know, like, it all, it was such a cool, like, counterpart. Like, it made me feel like, ooh, I really, like,
我觉得我真的理解这种动态，你知道吗？我觉得在很多方面是你让我得到了这个角色。不可能。是的，不，你做到了。好吧，我在房间里和你也有同样的经历，这和他们把我与约翰（John）配对时非常相似。
I feel like I really get this dynamic, you know? And I feel like you, you kind of got me the part in a lot of ways. No way. Yes, no, you did. Well, I had that same experience with you in the room, and it's very similar to when they paired me up with John.
我当时想，哦，当我与这个人配对时，我就变成了帕姆。我想我和两三个人一起读过，迈克问我，那么你觉得呢？你喜欢谁？我只是不停地、不停地、不停地、不停地、不停地谈论你。我说，我的意思是，她太棒了。我告诉了他所有那些事情。她让扮演帕姆变得如此容易。
I was like, oh, when I'm paired up with this person, I just turn into Pam. I think I read with two or three different people, and Mike asked me, so what do you think? Who do you like? And I just went on and on and on and on and on about you. And I was like, I mean, she was amazing. I told him all those things. She made it so easy to be Pam.
他说，好的，记下了。但他没说，哦，她是我大学最好的朋友。我迫不及待想告诉她。他表现得太冷静了。不，顺便说一句，对我也是，如果我真的想要一个角色，我可以和认识的人套近乎，这是最好的时机，但没有人会为我做任何事。
And he was like, okay, noted. But he didn't say, oh, she's my best friend from college. I can't wait to tell her. He was so, he played it so cool. No, and by the way, with me too, like I wish if there were a time I really wanted a part and I could like curry some a part and I had, I could like curry some favor with people I knew this was the time, but like nobody would do anything for me.
因为你知道格雷格也是这样。我的意思是，他问了每个人。他无法下定决心。还有另一个女人。他有点想在我们之间做决定。我来了很多次。我等了很久。迈克，你知道，迈克是那种有道德的迈克。所以他不会说，我要为你争取。他说，这必须是适合这个角色的人，每个人都必须同意。所以，这简直是折磨。他们真的，真的把我带到了最后关头。在我接到电话之前。我很高兴你得到了这个角色。它改变了我的整个职业生涯。是的。是的，在得到这个节目之前，我差点就放弃演戏了。所以这对我很重要。
Because you know how Greg is too. I mean, he was like asking everybody. He could not make up his mind. There was like another woman. He was kind of trying to decide between us. I came in so many times. I waited for so long. Mike, you know, Mike is like ethical Mike. So he wasn't going to be like, I'm gonna just I'm gonna gun for you. He was like, it has to be the right person for the part and everybody has to be on board. So like, it was towards it was torturous. Like, they really, really took me to the bitter end. Before I before I got the call. I'm so glad you got the part. It changed my whole career. Yeah. Yeah, I was like about to quit acting before I got this show. So it was a big deal for me.
对于珍娜和我来说，这是我第一次一口气重温整个《Benihana圣诞节》。是的。我见过一些小片段，因为你知道，那是《小鼓手男孩》（Little Drummer Boy），人们会给我发我表演那个的片段，但我没有真正坐下来看完它。
For Jenna and I, this was the first time I had rewatched the whole Benny Hanna Christmas, like all in one sitting. Yeah. I had seen little clips, cause you know, it's the little drummer boy and people like send me clips of me doing that, but I hadn't really sat down and watched it all.
你呢？这是你第一次重温它吗？是的，我没看过。我想自从它播出后我就没看过，我笑得太开心了。有几件事浮现在我脑海中。一个是，珍娜，我们终于得到了那个回报，就像试镜中展现的那种东西。我不认为它真的得到了体现
And what about you? Was this the first time you rewatched it?, but I hadn't really sat down and watched it all. And what about you? Was this the first time you rewatched it? Yes, I hadn't seen it. I don't think since it aired and I was giggling so much. And like a couple of things occurred to me. One was that we got that payoff, Jenna, finally, like that thing that like came to life in the audition. I don't think it really got to really manifest
直到这一集，你知道，因为到目前为止我们有点像竞争对手，就像试镜中展现的那种东西，我不认为它真的得到了体现直到这一集，你知道吗？因为到目前为止我们有点像竞争对手，就像在互相嗅对方的屁股。这听起来很恶心，但你知道我的意思。如果我们是狗，我们就会那样做。这是第一次，我想两个角色中的人性都认可了
until this episode, you know, because up to now we were kind of like rivals like that thing that like came to life in the audition, I don't think it really got to really manifest until this episode, you know? Because up to now we were kind of like rivals and like sniffing each other's butts. That sounds gross, but you know what I mean? If we were dogs, we would have been doing that. And this is the first time that like, I think the humanity in both characters recognized
对方身上共同的人性。就像是，你知道吗？这是圣诞节，我们在这些狭小的空间里工作，而且我们在安吉拉身上有一个共同的敌人。所以我们很容易就成为一个团队，我觉得这真的很酷。我不是想自吹自擂，但我认为我们在这一集中有惊人的化学反应。我只是，我的意思是，我们很可爱。我能说吗？你可以说。
the mutual humanity in the other one. And was like, you know what? Like it's Christmas and we work in this in these close quarters and also we have a common enemy in Angela. So it was like, it just was easy for us to, to, to like, to, to be a team, which I thought that was really cool. I don't mean to toot our own horns, but I think we had amazing chemistry in this episode. I just, I mean, we are adorable. Can I say it? You can say it.
你可以说。本来可以有一个衍生剧的。我只想说这么多。完全是帕姆和凯伦的圣诞特辑。是的。我可以告诉你们，我们在场景之间会聚在一起，我会开始大笑，和你们在一起。我会说，耶，我在聚会。
You could say it. There could have been a spinoff. That's all I just want to say. Totally Pam and Karen Christmas special. Yes. I can tell you guys, we would hang out between scenes, and I would just start cracking up and just be with you guys. I'd be like, yay, I'm hanging out.
是女孩们。然后像在“开始”的时候，我必须对你们俩都很刻薄。然后你们却有了这整个其他的聚会。这很难。我知道。菲利斯（Phyllis）真的能表达出她有多想念另一个派对。我没能参加，但这就是我的感受。
It's the girls. And then like on action, I had to be so mean to both of you. And then you like got to have this whole other hangout. It was hard. I know. Phyllis really gets to emote how much she's like missing the other party. I wasn't able to, but that's how I felt.
我知道，我知道，但这很好，因为它在这一集中都体现出来了，因为我们联手了。是的，是的。我们做了我们需要做的事，那就是教训你，帮助你停止那么爱控制。然后你还得唱歌，你知道吗？哦，天哪，我吓坏了。
I know, I know, but it's good because it all plays out in the episode because we like, we joined forces. Yeah, yeah. We did what we needed to do, which was just like teach you a lesson and help you to stop being so controlling. And then you got to sing, you know? Oh God, I was terrified.
伙计们，我不喜欢在别人面前唱歌。那真的很难。哦，天哪，听着，我在那个婚礼那一集里必须这样做，我们必须唱《警察乐队》（The Police），我太害怕了。你还记得那一集吗？那是谁的婚礼？那是菲利斯的婚礼吗？
I don't like singing in front of people, you guys. That was really hard. Oh God, I, listen, I had to do it at that, in that wedding episode, we had to sing the police and I was so scared. Do you remember that episode? Whose wedding was it? Is that Phyllis' wedding?
菲利斯的婚礼，是的。哦，是的。是的，再次观看这些剧集是一个有趣的时刻。你知道，珍娜和我谈过一点。这对我来说很有趣，现在重温它。你觉得怎么样？我的意思是，听着，这是我要说的第二件事，观看《办公室》。
Phyllis' wedding, yes. Oh yeah. Yeah. It is interesting time to watch these episodes again. You know, Jenna and I have talked about this a little bit. That was interesting for me to rewatch it now. How was it for you? I mean, listen, that was the second thing I was going to say is watching the off.
自从它播出后我就没看过这部剧。你知道，我想这部剧的很多内容，迈克尔的很多内容，以及关于迈克尔有效的地方，是完全尴尬和像意图良好、可爱、坏老板之间的微妙平衡。在当前的环境下观看它，那种平衡感觉不同。它感觉太不同了。我的意思是，有很多东西。它不是，它超越了尴尬。
I haven't watched the show since it aired. And you know, I think so much of the show and so much of Michael and the end, what works about Michael is this delicate balance between full cringe and like well intentioned, lovable, like bad boss. And to watch it now in the current climate, like that balance feels different. It just feels so different. I mean, there's so much stuff. It's not, it's beyond cringe.
就像，哇。但对我来说，就像，你知道，我认为现在有很多关于什么是可接受的对话，但也像回顾过去，我们被允许参与什么，你知道，在一个事情被认为更可接受的时代，即使它们不是，也不应该被接受。我认为拥有那些现在读起来很糟糕、但在当时读起来并不糟糕的东西是好的，因为它是我们进步的标志。
It's like, wow. But it's also to me, like, you know, I think there's so much conversation right now about what's acceptable, but also like in, in retrospect, what we're allowed to kind of partake in, you know, in a time where things were, were considered more acceptable, even if they weren't and they shouldn't be. I think it's good to have things that read really badly now and didn't read badly at the time because it is a mark of our progress.
而且这部剧之所以能引起共鸣，是因为迈克尔让人们想起了他们的老板和他们一起工作的人，也许还有一点他们自己。这真的很重要，人们看到你必须达到你所处的时刻。这部剧的很多内容就像人们忍受他的不良行为
And it's also like the show resonates because Michael reminds people of their bosses and people they work with and maybe a little bit of themselves. And it's like really important that people see that like you have to measure up to the moment that you're in. So much of the show is like people putting up with like his bad behavior
并且说，哦，天哪。现在我认为人们在工作中感到有武装，可以说，你知道吗？我不喜欢你谈论那个人或那个女人或那个什么的语气。就像，我不，那不再是可接受的行为。你可以说些什么，并作为一名员工感到有权这样做，你知道吗？所以这超级迷人。我认为很多时候我们在剧中作为角色，我们会通过给镜头一个眼神来表达不满
and being like, oh, my God. And now I think people feel armed at work to be like, you know what? I don't like the way you're talking about that person or that woman or that whatever. Like, I don't that's not acceptable behavior anymore. And you could say something and feel empowered as like an employee to do that, you know? So it was super fascinating. I think a lot of times we on the show as characters, we would speak up by giving a look to camera
或表示我们的不赞同。但你是对的。我想今天我们会直接当面说出来。迈克尔那种行为可能不会有工作了。不！那是太多次违规了，迈克尔。天哪。他就像一个人力资源噩梦。有趣的是，托比是敌人。就像托比在尝试，他很敏感，他试图照顾人们并保持宽容
or indicating our disapproval. But you're right. I think today we would speak up right to his face. Michael wouldn't have a job with that behavior probably. No! It's one too many infractions, Michael. Geez. He's like a human resources nightmare. And that's the funny thing too is that Toby is the enemy. Like Toby's trying to, like he's sensitive and he's trying to take care of people and be tolerant
迈克尔非常恨他，因为他毁了他的派对。而且，这感觉就像一段你今天甚至写不出来的关系，真的，你知道吗？格雷格给史蒂夫（Steve）的笔记之一是，当史蒂夫开始扮演迈克尔时，他把这个角色看作是一个认为詹妮弗·安妮斯顿（Jennifer Aniston）有一天可能会看到这盘录像带的家伙。
and like Michael hates him so much for it because he's killing his party. And like, that, this feels like a relationship you couldn't even write today, really, you know? One of the notes that Greg gave Steve when Steve was like starting to perform as Michael is that he saw the character as this guy who thinks maybe Jennifer Aniston might see this tape someday.
所以，就像，我从史蒂夫的表演中看到了迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）如何认为自己是一个艺人。他认为自己很有趣、很前卫、在挑战界限，但他只是太不合时宜了。但我以不同的方式看待他的表演，知道格雷格的那个笔记。完全正确。好吧，也因为有一个关于谁有权挑战界限的对话。我认为艺人们觉得他们可以，而普通人不能。所以迈克尔会认为他是那些艺人之一
Like, so to sort of play it like, and I so see in Steve's performance how Michael Scott thinks he's an entertainer. He thinks he's funny and cutting edge and pushing boundaries, and he's just so inappropriate. But I see his performance in a different way, knowing that note from Greg. Totally. Well, also because there's a conversation around who is entitled to push the boundaries. And I think that entertainers feel like they can in a way that normal people can't. And so it would make sense that, like, Michael would think he's one of those entertainers
而不是那些普通人之一，这说得通，你知道吗？哦，是的。是的。我们谈了很多关于派对策划委员会的场景，以及我们作为演员参与其中有多开心，对吧？是的。我只是喜欢，拉什达，你参与其中，你们，就像我们能坐在那里玩。那是最有趣的。太有趣了。特别是那个场景，拉什达，
and not one of those normal people, you know? Oh, yeah. Yeah. We have talked a lot about party planning committee scenes and how much fun we had getting to do them as actors, right? Yeah. And I just loved, loved Rashida that you got to be in on that and that you guys, like that we got to sit in there and play. That was the most fun. So fun. Particularly there's that scene Rashida
你试图参与派对。你试图提出一些你们过去在斯坦福（Stanford）参与派对的想法。你试图提出一些你们过去做过的事情，而安吉拉只是拒绝了你。是的，它们是好主意。抽奖。非常好。正如我们将看到的
where you try to participate in the party. You try to throw out some ideas of things you guys used to participate in the party. You try to throw out some ideas of things you guys used to do in Stanford and Angela just shuts you down. Yeah, they're like good ideas. A raffle. Very good. As we will see played out
在休息室里成功的派对中上演。她只是针对我。我的意思是，我实际上，我不往心里去。我想那只是，那是你闪耀的地方，那是你长期以来的委员会。好吧，就像那些只有一点点权力的人，但有了那种权力，它就意味着一切。是的。
in a successful party in the break room. She just had it out for me. I mean, I don't actually, I don't take it personally. I think it was just like, that was your place to shine and that was your committee for so long. Well, it's like the people that only have a tiny bit of power, but with that power, it just means everything. Yes.
在休息室举办了一场成功的派对。她就是针对我。我是说，我其实并没有，我没有往心里去。我觉得那就像是，那是你长期以来发光发热的地方，也是你的委员会。嗯，就像那些只有一点点权力的人，但对他们来说，那点权力就是一切。没错。
Everything. Yes. So I think that was the party planning committee was her thing. And if you messed with it, she spiraled out. There's a deleted talking head that's not in the episode, but it's on the DVDs. Oh. You're like, I spiraled out. There's a deleted talking head that's not in the episode, but it's on the DVD. You're like, I don't know, we didn't have a party planning committee in Stanford. Like, like, like, it's really funny because you're just like, why, why is
全部。是的。所以我认为那是派对策划委员会，那是她的地盘。如果你去干涉它，她就会崩溃。有一个被删减的采访片段没有出现在剧集中，但在DVD里。哦。你就像是，我崩溃了。有一个被删减的采访片段没有出现在剧集中，但在DVD里。你就像是，我不知道，我们在斯坦福没有派对策划委员会。就像，就像，这真的很有趣，因为你只是在想，为什么，为什么会有个委员会？就像，是的，我的意思是，我喜欢，我也喜欢那些场景。那些是我在剧中我最喜欢的场景，就是当你们都被困在一个房间里，场景里有一种节奏，因为A，即使我是犹太人，我也会忍不住笑场，但我确实会。而且，看着那种乒乓球式的对话真的很有趣，你知道，比如菲利斯的眼睛乱转，或者，你知道，比如凯特说，是的，请给我任何含酒精的东西，我加入，或者只是看着这些，我喜欢观察那种节奏，尤其是因为那是，我加入。或者，只是看着这些，我喜欢观察那种节奏，尤其是因为那是，那场戏全是女士，对吧？
there a committee? Like, Yeah, I mean, I love I also love those scenes. Those are my favorite scenes on the show is like when you're all kind of stuck in a room and there's like a rhythm to the scene because A, I get church giggles even though I'm Jewish, but I do. And also like, it's just so fun to watch the ping pong of like, you know, Phyllis's eyes dart or like, you know, like Kate be like, yes, like, please anything with alcohol, I'm in or like, just to see that I love watching the rhythm of like, especially because it was like, I'm in. Or like, just to see that I love watching the rhythm of like, especially cause it was like, it's all ladies that scene, right?
是的。是的。是的。这太有趣了。太棒了。拉什达，我必须提一下这个。我们一直在追踪这个。我称之为“摇摆不定的吉姆”。我想听听你对“摇摆不定的吉姆”的看法。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's just so fun. It was great. Rashida, I have to bring this up. We've been tracking this. I call it wishy washy Jim. And I want to get your take on wishy washy Jim.
我很恼火吉姆没有告诉凯伦他过去在邓德·米夫林和帕姆的事。她走进这个全新的世界，这一切。她一无所知。是的。然后，某种程度上，他也没有告诉帕姆他见过凯伦。所以有整整，比如好几集，这两个女人，凯伦被蒙在鼓里，帕姆感觉到了一些东西但试图弄清楚。嗯，我认为这说明了一个更大的问题，那就是在《办公室》宇宙的传说中，
I am annoyed that Jim did not tell Karen about his past with Pam at Dunder Mifflin. She walks into this whole world, this whole thing. She has no idea. Yeah. And then it's sort of, he doesn't tell Pam that he's seen Karen. So there's this whole, like many episodes where these two women, Karen is in the dark, Pam is like sensing something but trying to figure it out. Well, I think this speaks to a larger thing, which is like in the lore of the Office universe,
就像，你知道，我对凯伦在现代意味着什么感到不满，因为我认为无论是拉什达，拉什达绝对不是一个“凯伦”，甚至《办公室》里的凯伦也不是“凯伦”，因为她喜欢玩得开心。她不是告密者。她不是种族主义者。但无论如何，重点是，有这么一回事，对吧，凯伦在某种程度上被设计成三角形的第三个点，这被设计成一种东西，让人们觉得他们想要帕姆和吉姆更紧密地联系在一起，被推得更近。所以，我当时就像是一个工具，
like, you know, I take umbrage with like what Karen means now in the modern day, because I think neither neither Rashida Rashida is definitely not a Karen and even Karen is from the office is not Karen like, because she's she's up for a good time. She's not a tattletale. She's not a racist. But anyway, the point being, like, there is this thing right like Karen is sort of designed to be the third point in the triangle, which is was designed to be a thing to to like, make people feel like they wanted they wanted Pam and Jim to be drawn closer together driven closer together. So like I was kind of a tool
以那种方式，你知道，所以一切都是，我记得编剧们谈论过它，他们只是不想在任何方向上推得太远。但是是的，我认为最终的结果是吉姆对我对你来说都不太好，因为他并没有对任何人诚实。但我猜你可以把它归结为他的困惑，
in that way, you know, and and so everything was like, I remember like the writers talking about it, they just didn't wanna push anything too far in each direction. But yes, I think that the end result is that Jim ends up being like not great to me and not great to you because he's like not really being honest with anybody. But I guess you could chalk it up to his confusion
关于他想要什么。是的。但我同意你的观点，这很令人恼火。而且我认为在现实生活中，那会非常烦人。你知道吗？是的。嗯，我想我在重温时发现，我更倾向于你的角色。
about what he wants. Yeah. But I agree with you, it's irritating. And I think in real life, that would be like super annoying. You know? Yeah. Well, I think what I found in the rewatch is that I am siding more with your character.
我同情她。当然，我希望吉姆和帕姆最终在一起，但与此同时，这让我喜欢这种张力。我只是觉得这个可怜的女人。她只是爱他。她只是——她什么都不知道。她什么都不知道。
I'm having sympathy for her. Like, of course I want Jim and Pam to end up together, but at the same time, it's making me like the tension. I just like this poor woman. She just loves him. She's just- She knows nothing. She knows nothing.
她什么都不知道。所以我不得不说，我非常倾向于你的角色。我是帕姆。那是帕姆的名字。帕姆就像是。有一个梗是说，对于从小看《办公室》长大的孩子们来说，就像是，当你意识到你讨厌凯伦的唯一原因是因为你希望帕姆和吉姆在一起，而你意识到她并没有做错任何事时的那种感觉。
She knows nothing. So it's making me very much side with your character, I have to say. And I'm Pam. That's Pam's name. Pam is like. There's like this meme that's like, like for kids who grew up watching The Office, it's like, like that feeling when you realize that the only reason you hated Karen was because you wanted Pam and Jim to be together and you realized that she did nothing wrong.
就像那是一回事。是的。现在这成了一回事，孩子们会说，这很酷。它为那些从小认为“那是敌人，那是想要在一起的人”的孩子们提供了一个机会，让他们以更细致的方式看待人们。现在他们会说，等一下。她其实没那么坏。只是我不想让她和他在一起。我想要她和它在一起，你知道吗？他们在成长，他们在学习。嗯，在你离开之前，你还有什么想要分享的回忆或幕后故事吗？甚至不需要是关于这一集的。可以是关于你在剧组的时光。你知道，看着它很有趣。我当时想，这让我真的很怀旧，因为它让我想起了所有那些小瞬间。而且，我不，你知道，我好久没谈过这个了，但我只记得埃德和我，有一句台词是安迪在这一集中说的，
Like that's like a thing. Yeah. That's like a thing now where kids are like, which is kind of cool. It's like providing this opportunity to like see people in a more nuanced way for kids who grew up being like, that's the enemy and that's the people that want to be together. Now they're like, wait a second. She's like, not that bad. It's just that I wanted her not to be with him. I wanted her to be with it, you know? They're growing, they're learning. Well, before you leave, do you have any other memories or behind the scenes stories that you want to share? It doesn't even have to be about this episode. It could be about just your time on the show. You know, it's funny watching it. I was like, it made me really nostalgic because it just reminded me of all the like little moments. And like, I don't,'t you know like I haven't talked about in so long but I just remember like Ed and I there's a there's a line where Andy says in this episode
哦不，抱歉，是下一集，他说只剩下两个了，我将是最后一个站着的人，而他确实是最后一个站着的人，但你知道，埃德和我，这太奇怪了，因为我们开始于这个奇怪的、像《办公室》的异世界版本，除了约翰，你们都不在那里。然后我们转到真正和你们一起工作。然后我们不知道我们要待多久。我们签了四集，然后变成了10集。然后他们说是整整一年。但这是一种奇怪的事情，就像，发生了什么？因为我们就像是在这列小火车上，我们俩都只是，发生了什么？
oh no sorry it's the next episode where he goes there's only two left and I'm going to be the last man standing and he was the last man standing but like you know Ed and I were like it was so weird because we like started in this like weird like bizarro world version of the office where none of you guys were there except for John. And then we moved over to actually work with you guys. And then we didn't know how long we were going to be there. And we were signed up for four episodes and then it was like 10. And then they were like the whole year. But it was this weird thing that was like, what is going on? Because we were like on this little train together where we were both like, just like, what's going on?
这对我们俩来说都是一个疯狂的、巨大的机会。我们会在我们的拖车里，我们的小拖车里进行这些小聚会，只是试图核对一下，看看发生了什么。这对我来说真的是一个游戏规则的改变者。而且每个人对我都很友善。每个人都对我很好。每个人在剧组里都太不同了。所以，我想只是为了了解你们所有人，
This is like a crazy, huge opportunity for both of us. And we would just have these little like powwows at our trailer, our tiny little trailers and just like try to check in and see what was going on. It really was like it's such a game changer for me. And like and everybody was so nice to me. And it just just everybody was everybody nice to me. And it just, just everybody was, everybody's so different on the show. So like, I think just to like get to know you all
还有菲利斯，女士们是我最喜欢的。这对我的人生来说是一个非常具有塑造性的时期，你知道吗？是的。确实是。嗯，拉什达，我们也爱你。我知道我们可能应该结束你的采访了，因为我们可以和你聊上一辈子。但我想要给#blackAF打个小广告。
and Phyllis, like the ladies were like my favorite. Like just so it was such a like formative time for me in my life, you know? Yeah. Really was. Well, Rashida, we loved you too. And I know we should probably wrap up your interview because we could talk to you forever. But I want to give a little shout out to hashtag black AF.
能再次和你一起工作真是太有趣了。你在里面太搞笑了。你扮演乔亚。是的。那是一个非常有趣的角色。太有趣了。她太复杂了。她确实太复杂了。
It was so fun to get to work with you again. You're so hilarious in this. You play Joya. Yeah. That's such a fun character. So fun. She's so complicated. She is so complicated.
她太有层次了。她就像是一个好妈妈，也是一个糟糕的妈妈。她在婚姻中一团糟。我知道。它也是以伪纪录片的形式拍摄的。前提是你的女儿正在为你家拍摄这部纪录片，她的爸爸，他是这部电视剧的编剧和创作者。
She's so layered. Like she's like a good mom and she's a crappy mom. She's all over the place in her marriage. I know. It's done in the mockumentary style, too. The premise is that your daughter is doing this documentary of your family, her dad, who's this writer and creator of a TV show.
而且这是代替她的大学申请论文，对吧？是这个主意吗？是的。所以你们会进行采访，但她也像是在捕捉视频，然后更正式地。有时你们会为镜头表演一点点。一点点。
And it's in place of her college essay, right? Is that the idea? Yeah. And so you guys do talking heads, but she's also like capturing video and then more formally. Sometimes you guys are performing for the camera a little bit. A little bit.
因为你知道它在那里。拉什达，你是一位如此出色的编剧、导演、表演者、演员。还有什么我们可以分享的吗？我的意思是，哦，我制作了一个在Quibi上的节目，我很喜欢，我认为如果他们有Quibi，每个人都应该去看，或者如果他们没有，那么他们可以，我不知道，试用一下什么的。
As you know it's there. Rashida, you're such an amazing writer, director, performer, actress. Is there anything else we can share? I mean, oh, I produced a show that's on Quibi that I love and I think everybody should go watch if they have Quibi or if they don't, then they can, I don't know, get a trial or something.
我的朋友莫里斯·哈里斯，他是一位美丽的插花师、艺术家、舞者，他就像一个神奇的人。我们制作了这个名为《Centerpiece》的节目，他会和一位艺术家坐下来，谈论他们的创作过程、生活和童年。然后他会创作出这个美丽的、神奇的中心装饰品。就像是他们生活、艺术和旅程的化身。这就像是
My friend Maurice Harris, he's this beautiful florist, artist, dancer, he's just like a magical person. And we produced this show called Centerpiece, which is where he sits with an artist and they talk about their process and their life and their childhood. And then he creates this beautiful like magical centerpiece. That's like the embodiment of their life and art and journey. And it's just like
一个很酷、很棒的小型励志节目。我想看它。我想看《Centerpiece》。是的，《Centerpiece》。好的，伙计们。嗯，拉什达，非常非常感谢你。谢谢。太有趣了。我会回来的。回来吧。我的意思是，你没有邀请我，但如果你邀请我，我会回来的。好的。好的。你正式被邀请了，你也会正式回来。我等不及了。太棒了。拉什达，我希望我们能再次去坐船。我知道。我们会播客的。我确实喜欢船。
a cool, like wonderful little inspiring show. I want to see it. I want to centerpiece. Yeah, centerpiece. Okay, guys. Well, Rashida, thank you so, so much. Thank you. So fun. I'll come back. Come back. I mean, you didn't invite me, but if you invite me, I will come back. Okay. Okay. You are officially invited and you will officially come back. I can't wait. Great. Rashida, I hope we get to go on a boat again. I know. We'll podcast. I do love a boat.
所以我可以成为你船上播客的常驻角色。船上播客？商标。商标。与珍娜和安吉拉一起的船上播客，特别嘉宾拉什达·琼斯。天哪，我喜欢它。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。女士，你知道吗，工作场所压力现在是导致心理健康下降的首要原因之一，全球61%的劳动力经历着高于正常水平的压力？
So I can be the recurring character on your boat cast. Boat cast? Trademark. Trademark. Boat casting with Jenna and Angela with special guest Rashida Jones. Oh my God, I love it. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady did you know that workplace stress is now one of the top causes of declining mental health with 61% of the global workforce experiencing higher than normal levels of stress?
我不知道。嗯，我们不能就这样和这些事情说再见。嗯，我们不能就这样和这些事情说再见，你知道吗？我们不能就这样和工作说再见，但你可以开始关注健康。是的，这种对健康的关注可以以多种形式出现。对我来说，可以是散步。你可以在BetterHelp上联系治疗师。拥有超过35,000名治疗师，
I did not know that. Well we can't just say goodbye to these things,. Well, we can't just say goodbye to these things, you know? We can't just say goodbye to work, but you can start a focus on wellness. Yes, and that focus on wellness can come in many forms. It can be for me taking a walk. You could reach out to a therapist on BetterHelp. With over 35,000 therapists,
BetterHelp是世界上最大的在线治疗平台。他们已经在全球服务了超过500万人。而且很方便。你可以点击一个按钮就加入与治疗师的会话。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以提供接触具有多种专业知识的心理健康专业人员的机会。用BetterHelp从工作中放松下来。我们的听众在betterhelp.com/officeladies上首次购买可享受10%的折扣。那是betterhelp, h-e-l-p点com斜杠officeladies。夏天是你自己创造的。
BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform. They've served over 5 million people globally. It's convenient too. You can join a session with a therapist at the click of a button. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Unwind from work with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp, h-e-l-p dot com slash office ladies. Summer is what you make of it.
蒂姆霍顿的果味脆片能满足各种心情。所以从各种果味中选择，有气泡的、冷冻的或柠檬水的。今天就在蒂姆的应用程序上订购，在加拿大的参与餐厅限时供应。好了，伙计们，我们回来了，因为这是一个圣诞奇迹。德怀特撞死了一只鹅。这是一个圣诞奇迹。他就是这么说的。然后他把它扔在你的桌子上。是的，他把一只死鹅扔在帕姆的桌子上。
And Tim Horton's fruit crunchers have something for every mood. So choose from a variety of fruity flavors in sparkling, frozen, or lemonade. Order yours on the Tim's app today at participating restaurants in Canada for a limited time. All right, guys, we're back because it's a Christmas miracle. Dwight has run over a goose. It's a Christmas miracle. That's what he says. And then he flops it on your desk. Yeah, he flops a dead goose on Pam's desk.
然后我最喜欢的是托比进来的时候，他说，德怀特，我们谈过这个了。他说我们谈了半个小时。是的，你必须停止把死动物带进办公室。嗯，我们有很多关于这个开场的粉丝问题，安吉拉。好的，让我们听听。这个总是让我很高兴。洛根·延瑟、凯拉·休厄尔、凯莉·赖斯、德米特拉·利祖和哈什塔·维尔马都问菲尔·谢伊是否制作了德怀特携带的那只鹅。
And then my favorite is when Toby comes in and he's like, Dwight, we've talked about this. He said we talked about it for like half an hour. Yeah, you have to stop bringing dead animals into the office. Well, we had a lot of fan questions about this cold open Angela. Okay, let's hear it. This one always delights me. Logan Yenser, Kayla Sewell, Carrie Rice, Demetra Lizou, and Harshita Verma all asked if Phil Shea made the goose that Dwight carries in.
他做了。他必须制作并找到那只鹅。那是菲尔·谢伊生活的又一天。你今天在做什么，菲尔？我在做一只死鹅。实际上，我在做五种不同类型的死鹅，然后我要给它们拍照。然后，你知道，执行制片人和编剧
He did. He had to make and find that goose. That's another day in the life of Phil Shea. What are you doing today, Phil? I'm making a dead goose. Actually, I'm making five different types of dead gooses and then I'm gonna take photos of them. And then, you know, the executive producers and writers
会挑选哪只死鹅，但我有八只死鹅，你知道我的意思吗？没错，这就是菲尔·谢伊那周做的更多事情。是的，他会有一个死鹅的作品集。珍娜，很多人都围在帕姆的桌子旁讨论这件事。菲利斯、凯文、克里德、吉姆、托比，他们都在讨论这个。
are gonna pick which dead goose, but I have eight dead gooses, you know what I mean? Exactly, that's more of what Phil Shea did that week. Yeah, he's gonna have like a portfolio of dead geese. Jenna, so many people have huddled around Pam's desk about this. Phyllis, Kevin, Creed, Jim, Toby, they're all discussing this.
每个人都觉得恶心，除了菲利斯。是的，菲利斯有点像是，这看起来很合理。她对此没有任何问题。那是怎么回事？那是怎么回事？我的意思是，我的意思是，我觉得这是第一次，如果我错了请纠正我，互联网上的朋友们，这是克里德第一次说某件事很疯狂。克里德说，那太疯狂了。
Everyone is grossed out, but Phyllis. Yeah, Phyllis is kind of like, that seems reasonable. She's got no problem with it. What's that about? What is that about? I mean, I mean, I feel like this is the first time ever, quote me if I'm wrong out there, internet folks, this is the first time that Creed says something is crazy. Creed is like, that's crazy.
嗯，我们有一个粉丝发现，安吉拉。尼亚·肖、克里斯蒂安·哈珀、金伯利·克拉森和丽贝卡·麦卡利斯特都注意到，当克里德在这个开场中发表关于鹅的看法时，在下一场戏中他进来上班并拿走了一个玩具。是的！在四分十秒，克里德突然第一次到达。他穿着外套，整个人。我当时想，等等，那是连续性错误。所以我们可能是在不同的一天拍摄那个开场的，对吧？嗯，猜猜怎么着，安吉？我回到了旧剧本。关于鹅的整个开场
Well we've got a fan catch, Angela. Nya Shaw, Christian Harper, Kimberly Klassen, and Rebecca McAllister all noticed that while Creed is in this cold open, giving his two cents about the goose, in the next scene he enters for the day and takes a toy. Yes! At four minutes, ten seconds, all of a sudden Creed is arriving for the first time. He's in his coat the whole thing. And I was like, wait, that's continuity error. So we probably shot that cold open a different day, right? Well, guess what, Ange? I went back to the old script-a-roony. And this entire cold open about the goose
甚至不在里面。他们添加了它。他们添加了它。他们添加了它。这场戏的原始开头是迈克尔骑着自行车进来。所以我们拍摄了这个开场并稍后添加了它，有人显然只是忘记了
is not even in there. They added it. They added it. They added it. The original beginning of this scene was Michael riding in on his bike. So we shot this cold open and added it later and somebody obviously just forgot
克里德还不应该在上班。是的，嗯，我有一个小小的克里德发现，我称之为“尖刺克里德发型”。哦，好的。我们在这一集中有一些经典的尖刺克里德发型。好的。我的意思是，字面上它就像这样。我想截个屏
that Creed shouldn't be at work yet. Yeah, well, I have a little bit of a Creed catch that I'm gonna call spiky Creed hair. Oh, okay. And we got some classic spiky Creed hair in this one. All right. I mean, literally it's like this. Like I wanna take a screen grab of it
然后发给克里德，说，这是你发型的哪个阶段？它非常蓬松。它是蓬松的。我会描述它，我想截个屏
and text it to Creed and be like, what was this phase of your hair? It's very floofy. It's floofy. I would describe it I want to take a screen grab of it and text it to Creed and be like, what was this phase of your hair? It's very floofy. I would describe it more like floofy than spiky. Okay, floofy Creed hair. Track it. Okay, I've taken us on a hair tangent, but let's get back to the episode.
然后发给克里德，说，这是你发型的哪个阶段？它非常蓬松。它是蓬松的。我会描述它比尖刺更蓬松。好的，蓬松的克里德发型。追踪它。好的，我把我们带到了发型的题外话，但让我们回到这一集。
Do you remember Steve trying to ride that bike in. I about fell off my couch laughing from the memory of shooting that scene of Steve riding the bicycle into the office. When he curses, that was Steve. And they bleeped it out and it was so funny and you can almost start to see him break. But that was like, I feel like that was take like 72 or something. And he was like, you guys, you have to understand there was not a lot of space there. And it was like, it was like, like an S. Do you know what I mean? So you had to come out of that elevator and then about five steps, there's like a hard right.
你还记得史蒂夫试图骑那辆自行车进来吗？我从拍摄史蒂夫骑自行车进入办公室的那场戏的回忆中笑得差点从沙发上掉下来。当他咒骂时，那是史蒂夫。他们把它消音了，这太搞笑了，你几乎可以看到他要笑场了。但那感觉像是第72次拍摄什么的。他说，你们，你们必须明白那里没有多少空间。而且它就像，它就像，像一个S。你知道我的意思吗？所以你必须从电梯里出来，然后大约五步，有一个急转弯。
And there's like a left, then a right. And he had to get on a bike and balance and then try to maneuver this really quick zigzag into the office in one take. And it was not easy. So then Michael does something in this episode that I just love so much, cause I love a Christmas pun. I really enjoy them.
然后有一个左转，再一个右转。他必须骑上一辆自行车并保持平衡，然后试图在一次拍摄中完成这个非常快速的之字形进入办公室。这并不容易。所以迈克尔在这一集中做了一些我非常喜欢的事情，因为我喜欢圣诞双关语。我真的很喜欢它们。
I also really enjoy any pun in like the hair salon genre, if you will. The hair salon puns are the best. Like, hair today gone tomorrow. Like, I love all those. Now let me ask you this question. Is that hair like hair on your head? Yes, it's a hair Yes! Hair like a rabbit.
我也很喜欢美发沙龙类型的任何双关语，如果你愿意的话。美发沙龙的双关语是最好的。比如，今天有头发，明天就没了。比如，我喜欢所有这些。现在让我问你这个问题。那是头发，就像你头上的头发吗？是的，它是头发，是的！像兔子一样的头发。
Hair today, gone tomorrow. And then it's like a rabbit hopping away. Why would, if you were a hair salon, why would you have a rabbit and not use the word hair? If you were a hair salon, why would you use the pun hair today, gone tomorrow? Because they do. Oh, because they cut it off. Yes. Oh, lady. Okay, anyway.
今天有头发，明天就没了。然后它就像一只兔子跳走了。为什么，如果你是一家美发沙龙，你为什么要养一只兔子而不使用“头发”这个词？如果你是一家美发沙龙，你为什么要使用“今天有头发，明天就没了”这个双关语？因为他们确实这么做。哦，因为他们把它剪掉了。是的。哦，女士。好吧，无论如何。
So he hits Pam with a whole bunch of Christmas puns. I can't believe you're just getting that. What's happening? So he just is about to lay them out one after another. He's like, I would like a nice slice of Christmas Pam with a side of candy Pams or perhaps some Pam chops. He's just like, boom, boom, boom. He really does.
所以他用一大堆圣诞双关语攻击帕姆。我不敢相信你才刚刚明白。发生了什么？所以他只是准备一个接一个地把它们说出来。他说，我想要一片不错的圣诞帕姆，配上一份糖果帕姆，或者也许是一些帕姆排。他只是，砰，砰，砰。他确实是这样。
While Michael has a talking head where he says it's going to be the best Christmas ever because his girlfriend Carol is coming to the Christmas party and he has a surprise for her. Two tickets to Sandals Resort, Jamaica. It's all inclusive. He's just so proud that this resort is all inclusive. It's his selling point as he tries to get many women
当迈克尔有一个采访片段时，他说这将是有史以来最好的圣诞节，因为他的女朋友卡罗尔要来参加圣诞派对，他有一个惊喜给她。两张去牙买加桑德尔斯度假村的票。全包式的。他为这个度假村是全包式的感到非常自豪。这是他的卖点，因为他试图让许多女性
to go on this trip with him. So guys, now Carol enters and she's looking for Michael. She goes in his office and she confronts him. She's upset that he photoshopped a picture of himself onto her old family ski trip photo with her ex-husband and he sent it out to people with the message, Skis and Greetings. He says, A Christmas Carol. Skis and greetings. Fan question from Allison Catrion, Sarah, Joe, Lisa, and Elise. Were the kids in the Christmas card photo actually
和他一起去旅行。所以伙计们，现在卡罗尔进来了，她在找迈克尔。她走进他的办公室，和他对质。她很生气，因为他把自己的照片PS到了她和前夫的旧家庭滑雪旅行照片上，并把它发给了人们，信息是，“滑雪和问候”。他说，一个圣诞卡罗尔。滑雪和问候。来自艾莉森·卡特里恩、莎拉、乔、丽莎和伊莉丝的粉丝问题。圣诞贺卡照片里的孩子们真的是
Steve and Nancy's since they were married in real life? No. No. They had Nancy pose for a photo with a couple of kids and a really tall guy that was going to be her ex-husband. And then they Photoshopped Steve's face onto his face. But those are not Steve and Nancy's kids in real life. I like that it's a crappy Photoshop, because I believe it.
史蒂夫和南希的，因为他们在现实生活中结婚了？不。不。他们让南希和一个孩子以及一个非常高的男人拍了一张照片，那个人将是她的前夫。然后他们把史蒂夫的脸PS到了他的脸上。但那些在现实生活中不是史蒂夫和南希的孩子。我喜欢这是一个糟糕的PS，因为我相信它。
You know, it's not even well done. Well, we've seen Michael's Photoshop skills from when he Photoshopped us in that office group photo. Yes. So he clearly has not learned anything from then until now. But Carol ends up breaking up with Michael. And Michael is devastated because he's like, no, Carol, can I tempt you to stay with me
你知道，它甚至做得不好。嗯，我们从迈克尔把我们PS进那张办公室合影时就见过他的PS技巧了。是的。所以他显然从那时到现在什么都没学到。但卡罗尔最终和迈克尔分手了。迈克尔很崩溃，因为他说，不，卡罗尔，我能诱惑你留下来陪我吗
so that we can go to the all-inclusive Sandals Resort? We leave day after tomorrow. Well, I mean, Michael, come on. She's a single mom with two kids. You can't spring a surprise trip. That's not to say you already did a grand proposal to her. Now you have photoshopped your head on her ex-husband and now you're going to like try to say, but we have this last-minute trip that you haven't planned for. this will seal the deal. I thought the same thing. I was like, she has two small children.
这样我们就可以去全包式的桑德尔斯度假村了？我们后天就走。嗯，我的意思是，迈克尔，拜托。她是一个带着两个孩子的单身母亲。你不能突然搞一个惊喜旅行。这并不是说你已经向她求婚了。现在你已经把你的头PS到了她前夫身上，现在你又要试图说，但我们有这个你还没计划的最后一分钟旅行。这会达成交易。我也这么想。我当时想，她有两个小孩。
It is the holidays. You think she doesn't have her own holiday traditions and a very complicated like custody arrangement probably. You think she can just fly off to Sandals, Jamaica with 48 hours notice. This is just another example of the disconnect here for Michael and this relationship. Yeah, by the way, once you have young children,
现在是假期。你以为她没有自己的节日传统和一个非常复杂的监护安排吗？你以为她可以只提前48小时就飞往牙买加的桑德尔斯吗？这只是迈克尔和这段关系之间脱节的另一个例子。是的，顺便说一句，一旦你有了年幼的孩子，
there's no last minute anything. No. As far as like your adult life, you don't just get to go out to dinner last minute or meet people for drinks last minute or take a trip last minute. Those days are over. Michael and Carol have a pretty fantastic breakup moment if you're Carol because it's sort of a power play. Michael goes, you walk out that door and it's over.
就没有最后一分钟的任何事情了。不。就你的成年生活而言，你不能只是最后一分钟出去吃晚饭，或者最后一分钟和人见面喝酒，或者最后一分钟去旅行。那些日子结束了。迈克尔和卡罗尔有一个非常棒的分手时刻，如果你是卡罗尔的话，因为这算是一种权力游戏。迈克尔说，你走出那扇门，一切就结束了。
And Carol goes, I know. It's kind of like boss lady moment. Yeah, I know. I'm walking out the door, baby, bye. Should we talk about another gift that doesn't go well in this episode, Pam's gift to Jim? You mean the scene that I just wrote on my note card as, ooh. Yeah. Oof, ouch.
卡罗尔说，我知道。这有点像老板娘时刻。是的，我知道。我正走出那扇门，宝贝，再见。我们应该谈谈这一集中另一个不太顺利的礼物吗，帕姆给吉姆的礼物？你是说我刚才在笔记卡上写着“噢”的那场戏吗？是的。哎呀，痛。
Pam calls Jim over to her desk and she's like, hey, I need to give you your present early. I've been sending Dwight communications from the CIA for a couple of months and the gift is that you get to decide his final mission. She's so excited. She has a little red folder she's handing him. She's so excited that this is just going to tickle
帕姆把吉姆叫到她的桌子旁，她说，嘿，我需要提前给你你的礼物。我已经给德怀特发了几个月的中央情报局通讯，礼物就是你可以决定他的最终任务。她太兴奋了。她有一个小红文件夹要递给他。她太兴奋了，这只会让
Jim and they're going to be back together in their prank wars with Dwight. But Jim turns her down. He's like, you know what? I just don't think I should be doing this anymore because of my promotion. But then he has a talking head where he says he can't fall back into doing all the things he used
吉姆感到高兴，他们将回到与德怀特的恶作剧战争中。但吉姆拒绝了她。他说，你知道吗？我只是觉得我不应该再这样做了，因为我的晋升。但后来他有一个采访片段，他说他不能再回到做他过去做的一切事情了。否则，意义何在？他说这是一个重新开始的机会。那一定很痛。当他走开没有拿文件夹时，帕姆，只是拿着这个装满荒谬中央情报局信件的文件夹。你的表情，很痛苦。是的。
to do. Otherwise, what's the point? He said it's a chance to start over. That one had to hurt. When he walked away and didn't take the folder and Pam, it's just holding this folder of these ridiculous CIA letters. Your look, it's painful. Yeah.
嗯，现在迈克尔崩溃了，因为卡罗尔和他分手了，他走出来说，圣诞节取消了。他要取消它。斯坦利说，你不能取消一个节日。迈克尔快要哭了，他说，吉姆，把新年从斯坦利那里拿走。就像，他真的快要崩溃了。嗯，女士，你注意到在八分47秒，
Well, now Michael is devastated because Carol has broken up with him and he comes out and he says, Christmas is canceled. He's canceling it. And Stanley's like, you can't cancel a holiday. And Michael is like on the verge of tears and he's like, Jim, take New Year's away from Stanley. Like, he's really about to spiral out. Well, lady, did you notice that eight minutes and 47 seconds,
有一个会计堆叠的惊人镜头吗？我说会计堆叠，但和安迪一起。是的。你们就在那里。你们都站在会计堆叠的桌子边缘。我们站在那里，这是你第一次看到我非常讨厌的那件衬衫。
there is an amazing shot of the accountant's stack? I say the accounting stack, but with Andy. Yeah. There you guys are. You're all standing there at the edge of the desks in your accountant's stack. We're standing there, and this is the first shot you get of the blouse I absolutely hated.
我非常讨厌这件衬衫，因为它有，我数了数，32个扣子。什么？32个扣子，它们是微小的珍珠扁平扣子，就像你的小指指甲那么大，就像微小的，我必须扣上32个扣子，他们真的会敲我的门，说，安吉拉，他们在片场准备好了，我还在扣扣子。嗯，你不能只是解开几个然后把它从头上套进去吗？不，不，因为腋下太紧了。我必须，它们一直扣到我的脖子顶端。它就像一个高领扣子，全是扣子。女士。哇。我记得
I hated this blouse so much because it had and I counted 32 buttons. What? 32 buttons and they were tiny little pearl flat buttons like the size of like your pinky fingernail like tiny and I had to button 32 buttons and literally they would knock on my door like Angela they're ready for you on set and I'm like still buttoning well couldn't you have just undone a few of them and pulled it over your head no no because it was so fitted in the armpits. And I had and they buttoned all the way up to the top of my neck. It was like a turtleneck button and full of buttons. Lady. Wow. I remember
那个。现在你这么说。我记得那个微小扣子的周。我记得凯莉，我们的服装造型师对我说，如果我们曾经，曾经再用这件衬衫，我会拆掉这些扣子，换上魔术贴什么的。因为它让我们俩都快疯了。但我相信你再也没穿过那个。不，我想凯莉和我当时都想，算了吧。手臂上有扣子，从我的脖子上有扣子，一直到
that. Now that you're saying it. I remember the week of the tiny buttons. And I remember Carrie, our wardrobe stylist saying to me, if we ever, ever use the shirt again, I'm gonna strip out these buttons and put a Velcro or something. Because it was driving us both crazy. But I believe you never wore that again. No, I think Keri and I were both like, forget it. There were buttons down the arms, there were buttons from my neck, all the way like,
我的大腿。那件衬衫也太长了。我觉得那件衬衫对你的角色来说很好。不，它很完美。它太繁琐、蕾丝边，而且……我知道。它就像老式的圣诞节。我戴着我的胡桃夹子
I mean, literally to my thigh. That shirt was so long too. I think it was such a good shirt for your character though. No, it was perfect. It was so fussy and lacy and... I know. It was like ye olde Christmas. And I had my Nutcracker.
胸针，因为对我来说，这个派对的主题非常明确。嗯，我认为这很好地引导我们进入会议室进行关于胡桃夹子圣诞节的PPC会议，你以侮辱菲利斯开始。是的，我很生气，我把它发泄在菲利斯身上，重复。那就是安吉拉·马丁。
I had my Nutcracker pin on because for me, the theme was very clear of this party. Well, I think this leads us very well into the conference room for our PPC meeting on the Nutcracker Christmas, which you start by insulting Phyllis. Yeah, I'm mad and I take it out on Phyllis and repeat. That is Angela Martin.
我告诉菲利斯去拿绿色飘带，菲利斯给了我一点菲利斯的傲慢，说，我以为你说绿色是妓女般的。我的意思是，安吉拉受不了。她说，不，橙色是妓女般的。那是菲利斯穿的颜色。嗯，嗯，嗯。嗯，凯伦现在决定提出一些传统，
I tell Phyllis to get green streamers and Phyllis gives me a little Phyllis sass and says, I thought you said green was horish. And I mean, Angela is not having it. She's like, no, orange is horish. Which is the color that Phyllis was wearing. Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Well, Karen now decides to propose a few traditions that
在斯坦福很典型。我们有抽奖，我们有卡拉OK，安吉拉只是关闭了一切，然后把凯伦赶出了会议。嗯，她建议一个圣诞饮酒游戏，我说，上帝保佑你。就是这样。我护送她到门口。安吉拉只是太生气了。她开始时很生气。她结束时也很生气。但我喜欢珍娜，她只是不断地回到，它们都不在胡桃夹子圣诞节的主题上。胡桃夹子圣诞节。我不知道你是否曾经尝试过和一个非常非常注重主题的人协调派对？你有吗？在你的现实生活中？那是你吗，珍娜？
were typical at Stanford. We've got the raffle, we've got the karaoke, and Angela just shuts down everything and then throws Karen out of the meeting. Well, she suggests a Christmas drinking game, and I'm like, God help you. That's it. And I escort her to the door. Angela's just so ticked off. She starts off ticked off. She finishes ticked off. But I love Jenna that she just keeps going back to and none of them are on the theme of a nutcracker Christmas. A nutcracker Christmas. I don't know if you've ever tried to coordinate a party with someone who's very, very big on theme? Have you? In your real life? Is that you, Jenna?
嗯，这就是我要说的。我觉得也许当我们计划派对时你做过。我认为计划派对的人有两种。有一种人只是，哦，我们只是把它凑在一起，这有点像我。我只是，哦，是的，随便吧。让我们只是，我会抓取我们有的任何零食，我们会邀请人们。但还有一种人是，我需要一个主题，我们都要坚持这个主题。这是主题。如果你偏离了主题，我会很生气。还有珍娜。嗯，有趣的是，安吉拉，我觉得你会举办玛格丽塔卡拉OK派对。你会举办只有所有随机、最有趣东西的派对。
Well, that's what I was gonna say. I feel like maybe you've done that when we've planned a party. I think there are two types of people who plan parties. There's people who are just like, oh, we'll just throw it together, which is kind of me. I'm just like, Oh, yeah, whatever. Let's just, I'll grab whatever snacks we have and we'll just invite people. But then there's the people that are like, I need a theme and we're all going to stick to the theme. And here's the theme. And if you waver from the theme, I will be pissed off. And Jenna. Well, the funny thing, Angela, is I think you would throw the Margarita karaoke party. You would throw the party with just all the random, most fun stuff.
是的。你会举办胡桃夹子主题的派对，到处都会有胡桃夹子。是的。胡桃夹子饼干，胡桃夹子蛋糕。会有，我不知道，也许会有一份关于胡桃夹子历史的讲义。我不知道。我们有一份关于胡桃夹子历史的讲义，也许。我不知道。我们会让胡桃夹子在电视上播放，芭蕾舞。你知道我在说什么吗？是的。嗯，现在我们进入迈克尔的办公室，他在沉沦。
Yes. And you would throw the Nutcracker themed party and there'd be Nutcrackers everywhere. Yeah. Nutcracker cookies, Nutcracker cake. There would be, I don't know, maybe a handout on the history of the Nutcracker perhaps. I don't know. We a handout on the history of the Nutcracker, perhaps. I don't know. We'd have the Nutcracker playing on television, the ballet. You know what I'm saying? Yes. Well, now we go into Michael's office and he is wallowing.
他在听《Goodbye My Lover》的片段。但他没有购买它。只是一个片段。他只是在重复听免费的部分。再见我的爱，再见我的朋友。德怀特进来了，他说，我们要摆脱所有让你想起卡罗尔的东西。我们要摆脱所有这一切。德怀特确实做了那个经典的德怀特式的事情，当别人可能在受伤或试图忘记某事时，他认为他在帮忙，但他只是，哇，卡罗尔是一个非常好的
He's listening to a clip of Goodbye My Lover. He hasn't purchased it though. Just a clip. He's just listening to the free part on repeat. Goodbye my love, goodbye my friend. And Dwight enters and he's like, we're getting rid of everything that reminds you of Carol. We're getting rid of all of it. Dwight does that classic Dwight thing though of while someone else is maybe hurting or trying to forget about something, he thinks he's helping, but he's just like, wow, Carol was a really good
房地产经纪人。哦，看她用这个霉菌做了什么。她就像是在翻阅她的公寓，像合同，并赞美她。她很聪明。是的。嗯，帕姆在接待处，她现在看到了凯伦。她有一个采访片段，她说，我一直对凯伦有点冷淡，毫无理由。她从来没对我做过什么。然后我们看到帕姆走到凯伦的桌子旁，有点道歉，说，嘿，我真的很抱歉那次会议
realtor. Oh, look what she did with this mold. She's like going through her condo, like contract and like praising her. She's smart. Yeah. Well, Pam is over at reception and she sees Karen now. She has a talking head where she says, I've been a little cold to Karen for no reason. She's never done anything to me. Then we see Pam walk over to Karen's desk and kind of apologize and say, hey, I'm really sorry that meeting
是那样的，安吉拉很刻薄。现在我想帕姆和凯伦要建立联系了。如果你看吉姆脸上的镜头，太好了。他就像，发生了什么？是的。嗯，听着，我的意思是，我觉得吉姆在这一集开始时设定了一个明确的界限。他说，嘿，听着，现在情况不同了。
was like that, that Angela was mean. Now I guess Pam and Karen are going to bond. If you look at the shot of Jim's face, it's so good. He's like, what is happening? Yeah. Well, listen, I mean, I feel like Jim set a clear boundary at the beginning of the episode. He's like, hey, listen, things are different now.
我不会和你纠缠这个。我认为这有点像帕姆接受他的话，像是，好吧，你知道吗，我要站出来，我要以我没有和吉姆的过去时对待这个人的方式对待她。如果这个女人来到办公室，我会这样表现，这就是我要表现的方式。是的，我想帕姆也在努力做一个成年人。嗯，现在战争开始了。我的意思是，安吉拉，当然，你知道，对菲利斯很糟糕。她们挂上了她们的标志。她说，这应该在两天前就挂上了。
I'm not gonna get into it with you. And I think this is a little bit of Pam taking him at his word and being like, okay, well, you know what, I'm going to step up and I'm going to treat this person the way I would treat them if I didn't have a past with Jim. If this woman came into the office, this is how I would behave and that's how I'm going to behave. Yeah, I think Pam is trying to be a grown-up too. Well, now the war has begun. I mean, Angela, of course, is, you know, being crappy to Phyllis. They're hanging up their sign. She's like, this should have been hung two
然后是谁进来了，把她们的标志挂在我的标志上面？是的。我们的派对也比你们的早15分钟开始，而且我们的海报颜色更鲜艳。阴险。凯莉说，这看起来很有趣。然后凯文走过来，安吉拉开始生气了。所以她撕掉了你的标志。我知道，然后凯伦撕掉了胡桃夹子圣诞节的标志。
days ago. And then who just comes in and hangs up their sign over my sign? Yeah. Our party also starts 15 minutes before yours, and our poster is more brightly colored. Shady. And Kelly says, this looks fun. And then Kevin walks over and Angela's getting ticked off. So she rips your sign down. I know, and then Karen rips down a Nutcracker Christmas sign.
我知道，开始了。有一个被删减的场景。所以就在我撕掉那张海报后，我的角色走到托比那里，像是，你必须取消她们的派对。我们不能有两个派对。这不是被批准的。她们没有预算，等等等等。她只是在对他大发雷霆。托比说她们可以举办她们的派对。这是一个自由的国家。因为她们可以举办她们的派对。这是一个自由的国家。我的角色扇了他一巴掌。
I know, it is on. And there is a deleted scene. So right after I ripped that poster down, my character goes over to Toby and is like, you have got to cancel their party. We can't have two parties. This isn't like sanctioned. They don't have a budget and on and on and on. She's just reading him the riot act. And Toby says they can throw their party. It's a free country. because they can throw their party. It's a free country. And my character slaps him across the face.
什么？是的。是的。然后托比像是，哎哟，那真的很痛。然后我说，我是在试图叫醒你。醒醒。只能有一个派对。然后托比像是，那真的真的很痛，你不能碰人。
What? Yes. Yes. And then Toby's like, ow, that really hurt. And then I say, I'm trying to wake you up. Wake up. There can only be one party. And then Toby's like, that really really hurt and you can't touch people.
你不能打人，我要写报告举报你。'" 哇。然后我对托比说，"'你知道吗？迈克尔是对的。你真可怜。'" 哇。我知道。嗯，所以，你知道，安吉拉，
You can't hit people and I'm gonna write you up.'" Wow. And then I say to Toby, "'You know what? Michael was right. You are pathetic.'" Wow. I know. Well, so, you know, Angela,
你在被删减的场景中没看到的是，她去找托比寻求帮助，但他没有帮助。所以现在回到真实的场景中，她去找德怀特。但会有一个进展。她很生气，她去找托比，他没帮她。现在她去找德怀特。是的。作为三号人物，他怎么能帮她？
what you didn't see in deleted scenes is that she goes to Toby for help and he's no help. So now back in the real scenes, she goes to Dwight. But there would have been a progression. She was mad, she went to Toby, he didn't help her. Now she goes to Dwight. Yes. As number three, how can he help her?
他走到接待处，帕姆和凯伦正在帕姆的电脑上。他说，我正在拆除你们的派对。我正在拆除你们的委员会，作为排名第三的人，我正在取消你们的派对。但后来吉姆作为排名第二的人走过来，他组建了一个单人委员会来确定派对策划
He walks over to reception where Pam and Karen are on Pam's computer. And he says, I am dismantling your party. I'm dismantling your committee, and I'm canceling your party as ranking number three. But then Jim walks up as ranking number two, and he assembles a one-man committee to determine the validity of the party planning
委员会的有效性。等等，我必须告诉你，这是他委员会的实际名称。准备好了吗？我喜欢有多少个委员会。所以有派对策划委员会，有计划派对的委员会。现在，吉姆是确定两个委员会有效性的委员会的唯一成员。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。珍娜，他决定了什么？
committees. Wait, I have to tell you, this is the actual name of his committee. Ready? I love how many committees there are. So there's the party planning committee, there's the committee to plan parties. Now, Jim is the sole member of the committee to determine the validity of the two committees. I love that. I love that. I love that. And Jenna, what does he decide?
他决定支持凯伦和帕姆。他说她们计划派对的委员会可以保留。德怀特问他是否可以成为确定两个委员会有效性的委员会的成员。吉姆说，拒绝许可。就是这样。所以现在迈克尔仍然在他的办公室里闷闷不乐，安迪邀请他去Benihana吃午饭来让他振作起来。然后迈克尔邀请了吉姆、瑞安和德怀特。但瑞安有一份美味的借口清单，说明他为什么不能去。他一个接一个地把它们都说了出来。他说，我感觉不太好。我有一堆
He decides in favor of Karen and Pam. He says their committee to plan parties can stand. Dwight asks if he could please become a member of the committee to determine the validity of the two committees. And Jim says, permission denied. There you go. So now Michael is still moping in his office and Andy invites him to lunch at Benihana to cheer him up. And then Michael invites Jim, Ryan and Dwight. But Ryan has a delicious list of excuses as to why he cannot go. He rattles them all off in a row. He says, I'm not feeling well. I've got a ton
工作要做。味精过敏，花生过敏，我昨晚刚在那里吃过。吉姆像是，哇，谢谢你拿走了所有的借口。然后瑞安说，医生预约，车子故障，足底疣，爷爷在二战中战斗过。他有一堆。他把它们保存在手机里。他说，我把它们保存在手机里。你必须保持敏锐，吉姆。是的，加油，吉姆。欢迎回来。我们有一个来自凯西·希尔顿的粉丝发现，她想让我们知道斯克兰顿或斯克兰顿附近根本没有Benihana。我查过了。他们在匹兹堡有一个，那是四个半小时的车程，在普利茅斯会议有一个，那是一个小时45分钟的车程。我们甚至没试过。我们
of work to do. MSG allergy, peanut allergy, I just ate there last night. Jim was like, wow, thanks for taking all of the excuses. And then Ryan goes, doctor appointment, car trouble, planner warts, granddad fought in World War II. He's got like a ton of them. He keeps them on his phone. He's like, I keep them on my phone. You have to like stay sharp, Jim. Yeah, step it up, Jim. Welcome back. We had a fan catch from Casey Hilton, who wants us to know that there is no Benihana in Scranton or even near Scranton. I looked that up. They have one in Pittsburgh, which is a four and a half hour drive and one in Plymouth meeting, which is a one hour and 45 minute drive. We didn't even try. We
只是像是，好吧，显然那里没有。我们只是，我们只是无论如何都要把它写进去。所以他们在Benihana找到了座位，你们都知道那是怎么回事。你们都坐在炉灶周围，对吧？是的。所以迈克尔和安迪坐在一起，吉姆，然后吉姆旁边有一个座位，但在德怀特进去之前，一对夫妇挤进去了。因为德怀特和安迪就像在摔跤。
just were like, okay, clearly there's not one there. We're just, we're just going to write it in anyway. So they're getting their table at Benihana and you guys know how it is. You all sit around like the stovetop, right? Yeah. And so Michael and Andy sit together in gym and then there's a seat next to gym, but a couple scoochies in there before Dwight can get in there. Cause Dwight and Andy were like wrestling
就觉得，好吧，显然那里没有位置了。我们还是要把他写进去。所以他们去Benihana餐厅订了桌，你们都知道那是怎么回事。大家都围坐在炉灶周围，对吧？是的。然后迈克尔和安迪坐在一起，吉姆也坐在一起，吉姆旁边还有一个座位，但在德怀特坐下之前，有几个人挤了进去。因为德怀特和安迪当时在打闹
for the seat next to Michael. And now there's a couple there. And you guys that have watched the podcast before, you will know Stephen Sox, our stand-in, is the man in the couple. He got to be in the scene, and I just love that. Well, you know, on IMDb, he is credited as playing the role of Justin Spitzer.
坐在迈克尔旁边。现在那里坐着一对情侣。之前看过播客的朋友们应该知道，我们的替身演员斯蒂芬·索克斯就是那对情侣中的男方。他有机会出现在镜头里，我真的很喜欢这一点。嗯，你知道，在IMDb上，他被列为饰演贾斯汀·斯皮策这个角色。
The name that they gave to the character sitting at the table is our writer's name, Justin Spitzer, played by our stand-in, Stephen Sox. I love that. Here's the thing. Now Dwight's on the other end of the table, and he's gonna have to shout throughout the rest of the time there at Benihana. He has to keep shouting. And he's really annoying, this couple in between.
他们给坐在桌旁的角色起的名字就是我们编剧的名字，贾斯汀·斯皮策，由我们的替身演员斯蒂芬·索克斯饰演。我喜欢这个。事情是这样的。现在德怀特坐在桌子的另一端，他不得不在接下来的时间里在贝尼哈纳餐厅大喊大叫。他必须一直喊。而且他真的很烦人，中间坐着这对情侣。
And Jenna, I was just like, I know it's for comedy's sake, but you know that couple would have been like, do you want wanna trade seats? So you're next to your friends. I thought the same thing. I thought the same thing. What, they want this guy shouting over them through the whole meal?
珍娜，我当时就想，我知道这是为了喜剧效果，但你知道那对情侣肯定会想，你想换个座位吗？这样你就能和你的朋友坐在一起了。我也这么想。我也这么想。怎么，他们想让这家伙在整顿饭期间一直对着他们大喊大叫吗？
No. Of course not. But you know what? Maybe they had already started to get their food or something and it just felt like a huge headache. I don't know, but they stay. They're like, no, we wanna be in the center of the table. We want to see the chef most clearly. I don't know what their motivation was for not letting
不。当然不想。但你知道吗？也许他们已经开始吃东西了，或者其他什么原因，这感觉就像一场巨大的头痛。我不知道，但他们留下来了。他们就像，不，我们想坐在桌子中间。我们想最清楚地看到厨师。我不知道他们不让这家伙和他的团队坐在一起的动机是什么，但是。
this guy sit with his group, but. So Michael is still being mopey, even though they're at Benihana. You know, he wants to call Carol. And Andy's like, uh-uh, let's start ordering drinks. He starts ordering this weird eggnog-socky concoction. It sounds disgusting. We had a fan question from Dan Solomon who wanted to know,
所以迈克尔仍然很沮丧，尽管他们是在贝尼哈纳餐厅。你知道，他想给卡罗尔打电话。而安迪说，呃-呃，我们开始点饮料吧。他开始点这种奇怪的蛋酒清酒混合饮料。听起来很恶心。我们有一个来自丹·所罗门的粉丝提问，他想知道，
was that a real drink or was it invented by the writers? It's a made-up drink. This is not a real drink. Angela, someone on cracked.com did an article where they made all kinds of fake cocktails from different TV shows. Like, they made cocktails from of fake cocktails from different TV shows like they made cocktails from 30 Rock and Parks and Rec and they did a review of this drink.
那是一种真正的饮料还是编剧发明的？这是一种虚构的饮料。这不是一种真正的饮料。安吉拉，cracked.com上有人写了一篇文章，他们制作了各种来自不同电视剧的假鸡尾酒。比如，他们制作了来自《我为喜剧狂》和《公园与游憩》的假鸡尾酒，他们对这种饮料进行了评论。
Just to remind you it is one part eggnog and three parts sake. Sounds so gross. Alright, here's what they had to say. Quote, All right, here's what they had to say. Quote, it looks like so many different disgusting things and none of them are anything I would want to put in my mouth. You can actually hear the eggnog curdling in the glass. Gross.
提醒你一下，它是一份蛋酒和三份清酒。听起来太恶心了。好吧，这是他们要说的。引用，好吧，这是他们要说的。引用，它看起来像许多不同的恶心东西，没有一样是我愿意放进嘴里的。你甚至能听到蛋酒在杯子里凝结的声音。恶心。
Then they said, it's not the worst thing I've ever had, but it is far from the best. The real problem lies in the aftertaste. Both of these drinks have a tendency to linger on the breath by themselves, and neither is very pleasant. When mixed together, they make your mouth taste like toes. I wish I could say something nice about this drink, but every time I attempt it, I suddenly forget all the good in my life. Oh my god. Well, what I want to know now is what were those guys actually drinking on the set?
然后他们说，这不是我喝过的最糟糕的东西，但远非最好。真正的问题在于余味。这两种饮料单独喝都有留在呼吸中的倾向，而且都不太令人愉快。混合在一起时，它们让你的嘴里尝起来像脚趾。我真希望我能对这种饮料说点好话，但每次我尝试时，我突然就忘记了生活中所有的美好。天哪。好吧，我现在想知道的是，那些人在片场到底在喝什么？
Were they drinking water mixed with eggnog? Were they just drinking eggnog? I don't know. I don't like eggnog, so I'm not a big eggnog person. I liked it as a kid, but as adult it's just it's very thick. It's like drinking a dessert. It's so sweet. Yeah. We should go back because I need to talk to you a little bit about this scene with Roy. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. So Roy comes in he's looking cute he clearly just wants to talk to Pam. He's asking her about her gift wrapping techniques and she says she
他们是在喝水混合蛋酒吗？他们只是在喝蛋酒吗？我不知道。我不喜欢蛋酒，所以我不是一个喜欢蛋酒的人。我小时候喜欢它，但作为成年人，它太浓了。就像在喝甜点。太甜了。是的。我们应该回去，因为我需要和你谈谈关于罗伊的这场戏。嗯哼。嗯哼。所以罗伊进来了，他看起来很可爱，他显然只是想和帕姆说话。他问她关于她的礼品包装技巧，她说她
only uses three pieces of tape. Are you crazy? Yeah. Well Angela, Adrian Thornblom, Sydney Layton and Alisa Schroeder and Kelly Lubert wrote in to say, how on earth can you wrap a gift with only three pieces of tape? How? Yeah. They are all saying there must be at least four. Why is Pam giving such bad advice here? Guys, it can be done. You can wrap a gift with three pieces of tape.
只用了三块胶带。你疯了吗？是的。嗯，安吉拉，阿德里安·索恩布洛姆，悉尼·莱顿和阿丽莎·施罗德以及凯利·卢伯特写信来说，你怎么可能只用三块胶带包装礼物？怎么做到的？是的。他们都说至少得有四块。为什么帕姆在这里给出这么糟糕的建议？伙计们，这是可以做到的。你可以用三块胶带包装礼物。
I personally, Jenna Fisher can't do it. I use more than three pieces of tape when I wrap a gift. But because Pam says this in this episode, every Christmas when I, Jenna Fischer, give a gift and I use more than three pieces of tape, people comment on it. Oh no, do they really? Yes, yes, they're like,
我个人，珍娜·费舍尔做不到。我包装礼物时用的胶带不止三块。但因为帕姆在这一集中这么说了，每年圣诞节当我，珍娜·费舍尔，送礼物并且用了不止三块胶带时，人们就会评论它。哦不，他们真的会吗？是的，是的，他们就像，
use more than three pieces of tape, eh? And I'm like, I am not Pam. I can't wrap, apparently Pam can. You can watch a ton of YouTube videos on how exactly Pam does it. Many people have made videos on how to wrap a gift with only three pieces of tape, so it can be done, but. Hold up, lady.
用了不止三块胶带，嗯？我就说，我不是帕姆。我不会包装，显然帕姆会。你可以看很多关于帕姆到底是怎么做的YouTube视频。很多人制作了关于如何只用三块胶带包装礼物的视频，所以这是可以做到的，但是。等等，女士。
Yeah. People commenting on your tape, that's gotta be in your family, because who you're giving, at Christmas, you're like with your family. So you've got like some aunt that's got to be in your family because who you're giving at Christmas you're like with your family so yeah you've got like some aunt that's like oh you use more than three bases yeah yeah i get grief i get grief from my family and some friends for not being your character yeah i mean that's the tricky thing about having a character that you played for a long time who makes grand declarations.
是的。人们评论你的胶带，那一定是在你的家庭里，因为你在圣诞节送礼物的人，你就像和你的家人在一起。所以你有一些阿姨，那一定是在你的家庭里，因为你在圣诞节送礼物的人，你就像和你的家人在一起，所以是的，你有一些阿姨，就像哦，你用了不止三块胶带，是的，是的，我从我的家人和一些朋友那里得到抱怨，因为我不是你的角色，是的，我的意思是，这就是拥有一个你扮演了很长时间并且会发表宏大声明的角色棘手的地方。
It gets superimposed onto me. But you know. Do you know what I get almost every single year from a family member? I get at least one gift that has a cat on it. Yeah. I like cats. Because Angela Martin likes cats.
它被叠加在我身上。但你知道。你知道我几乎每年都会从家庭成员那里得到什么吗？我至少会得到一份上面有猫的礼物。是的。我喜欢猫。因为安吉拉·马丁喜欢猫。
Yeah, I like cats. I don Because Angela Martin likes cats. Yeah. I like cats. I don't need a gift every year with a cat on it, guys, from my own family. My favorite is more than once, more than once, I have gotten a cat calendar, and there's usually a photo of a cat hanging for dear life from a tree and it says, hang in there. Yeah. I've gotten that calendar more than once.
是的，我喜欢猫。我不因为安吉拉·马丁喜欢猫。是的。我喜欢猫。我不需要每年都从我自己的家人那里得到一份有猫的礼物，伙计们。我最喜欢的是不止一次，不止一次，我得到了一个猫日历，通常有一张猫从树上垂死挣扎的照片，上面写着，坚持住。是的。我不止一次得到过那个日历。
Oh no. Okay, wait, wait, wait. We have to get back to the scene because they're flirting and then Karen sees the flirt, sees Roy and is like, he's cute. You should date him. And then Pam does not say a word. She doesn't own up. And she just says, maybe.
哦不。好吧，等等，等等。我们必须回到那个场景，因为他们在调情，然后凯伦看到了调情，看到了罗伊，就像，他很可爱。你应该和他约会。然后帕姆一句话也没说。她没有承认。她只是说，也许吧。
Well, I feel like Pam can't tell Karen that she used to be with Roy without it opening up a lot of questions that might lead her to having to tell her things that she knows Jim hasn't told her. I agree. Well, lady, I think we should pause our breakdown for this episode for a moment, because this is kind of the halfway mark, and we thought that this would be a good place
嗯，我觉得帕姆不能告诉凯伦她曾经和罗伊在一起，否则会引出很多问题，可能导致她不得不告诉她一些她知道吉姆没有告诉她的事情。我同意。嗯，女士，我想我们应该暂停一下这一集的解析，因为这差不多是中点，我们认为这是一个好地方
to play our interview with Jen Salata. Yeah, I think it would be great to hear from the writer of this episode before we dig any deeper. All right, Sam, will you play the interview with Jen? Hi, Jen Salata. Hi, Jen. Guys, look gorgeous. You look, it literally looks like time stopped
来播放我们对简·萨拉塔的采访。是的，我觉得在深入挖掘之前听听这一集的编剧的意见会很棒。好的，萨姆，你能播放对简的采访吗？嗨，简·萨拉塔。嗨，简。伙计们，看起来真漂亮。你看起来，字面上看起来就像时间停止了
since I last saw you. I love you. You stop it. I'm so excited. My favorite guests are when we have writers on because you guys have this perspective that is totally different from the actors and I could just listen to you guys have this perspective that is totally different from the actors, and I could just listen to you guys talk forever.
自从我上次见到你。我爱你。你停下。我太兴奋了。我最喜欢的嘉宾是当我们有编剧在场的时候，因为你们有这种与演员完全不同的视角，我可以一直听你们
It's my favorite side of the story. That and probably Phil Shea having to make all the weird props. All I remember about Phil Shea is constantly, if I had to come in on like a Saturday or a Sunday because I needed to do a little work or I forgot something at the office, he was always there. He was always there making a prop.
这是我最喜欢的故事侧面。那和可能菲尔·谢不得不制作所有奇怪的道具。关于菲尔·谢我记得的只有不断地，如果我必须在周六或周日进来，因为我需要做一点工作或者我忘记了办公室里的什么东西，他总是在那里。他总是在那里制作道具。
Like he just never stopped working. He was just brilliant. Yeah. My memory of him is him running. He was always like, like a cross and he had things in his hand. And I'd be like, Hey, I'll be like, Hey, I just got to attach this hat to the squirrel. And then I'm like, what? What made me laugh when you told me that he, I forgot that he presented everything on a tray and the bird thing made me laugh so hard because I'm sure that is, I can imagine that.
就像他从来没有停止工作一样。他只是太聪明了。是的。我对他的记忆是他奔跑的样子。他总是像，像一个十字架，手里拿着东西。我会说，嘿，我会说，嘿，我只是要把这顶帽子贴在松鼠身上。然后我就说，什么？当你告诉我他时，什么让我笑了，我忘了他在托盘上展示一切，鸟的事情让我笑得太厉害了，因为我确定那是，我可以想象那个。
I can picture that. And I wanted to tell you when I was listening to the bird stories that you guys were telling from your own home, but I Googled it. And I found out that there was an article about why we're seeing dead birds and birds that are struggling now. It's because of quarantine. It was the most interesting article. They said that we are just around and we're noticing nature more and we're more aware because we're not like in our offices all day long. So
我可以想象那个。当我在听你们从自己家里讲的鸟的故事时，我想告诉你，但我谷歌了一下。我发现有一篇文章关于为什么我们现在看到死鸟和挣扎的鸟。这是因为隔离。这是最有趣的文章。他们说我们只是在周围，我们更多地注意到自然，我们更清醒，因为我们不像整天在办公室里那样。所以
that unfortunately this is a time where birds struggle, but we don't usually see it. So I don't know if that's like yay or boo or somewhere in between, but I thought that was interesting. No it is. This is the big bird baby boom season this time of the year. And a big part of, because I looked it up too Jen, a big part of a bird's life cycle is that between the nest and being a full adult bird, they actually nest on the ground. So the parents kind of kick them out of the tree and they nest under bushes or on the ground for a couple of days and their parents visit them. But it's sort of like that's like they're going to college phase.
不幸的是，这是一个鸟类挣扎的时期，但我们通常看不到它。所以我不知道这是否是耶或嘘或介于两者之间，但我认为这很有趣。不，它是。这是每年的这个时候鸟类婴儿潮的季节。而且很大一部分，因为我也查了，简，鸟类生命周期的一大部分是，在巢穴和成为完全成年的鸟之间，它们实际上在地面上筑巢。所以父母有点把它们踢出树，它们在灌木丛下或地面上筑巢几天，它们的父母拜访它们。但这有点像它们去大学的阶段。
You know, they're out of the nest, but their parents are still kind of like sending a money from time to time. And so in that little period, like 80% of birds die because they are, you know, peril meets them. Maybe it's, you know, a raccoon or a cat or something. A squirrel. Yeah, this is the part of their life where they meet the most doom.
你知道，它们离开了巢，但它们的父母仍然有点像不时地给它们寄钱。所以在那个小时期，像80%的鸟类死亡，因为它们，你知道，危险遇到了它们。也许是，你知道，浣熊或猫或其他什么。松鼠。是的，这是它们生命中遇到最多厄运的部分。
Oh, this is sad. But I read that somebody rescued another person, like a bird fell into a pool, but they rescued it. So it's like, there may be more rescues happening because we're more aware and vigilant right now. Cut to next year, an article that says, a rise in birds due to people intervening and saving them has now bled us of all of the gnats.
哦，这很悲伤。但我读到有人救了另一个人，就像一只鸟掉进了游泳池，但他们救了它。所以就像，可能有更多的救援发生，因为我们现在更清醒和警惕。切到明年，一篇文章说，由于人们干预和拯救它们，鸟类数量上升，现在已经耗尽了我们所有的蚊蚋。
And it turns out gnats were necessary. Gnats were necessary. I know this is Beniana Christmas, and I'm sure you will deal with this. But like, I do remember reading articles that people's lives were saved because of staying alive in the safety training. Is it safety training in the episode? Stress CBR. Stress Relief. Stress Relief. Yeah. Because I remember I wrote that. I wrote that and I remember having to make sure I meant wanting to make sure it was correct
结果证明蚊蚋是必要的。蚊蚋是必要的。我知道这是贝尼哈纳圣诞节，我相信你会处理这个。但就像，我确实记得读过文章说人们的生命因为在安全培训中保持活力而得救。是那一集里的安全培训吗？压力心肺复苏。压力缓解。压力缓解。是的。因为我记得我写了那个。我写了那个，我记得必须确保我意味着想确保它是正确的
in case anybody watched the show and actually use it. But then I started to hear news reports that people remember it from the office and are saving people's lives from that. I've read those same articles. It's crazy. You're saving lives, Jen Salata. Well, I don't know. Jen, we always like to ask people
以防有人看节目并实际使用它。但后来我开始听到新闻报道说人们从办公室里记住了它，并从那里面拯救了人们的生命。我读过同样的那些文章。这太疯狂了。你在拯救生命，简·萨拉塔。嗯，我不知道。简，我们总是喜欢问人们
when they come on the podcast, how they got their job on the office. I was on the show Malcolm in the Middle, which I really enjoyed that show. But I every, every morning after the after the office aired, I would come in and just talk about the office forever. They were like, let's get to work on Malcolm stories. And I was like, yeah, yeah, sure.
当他们来到播客时，他们是如何在办公室得到工作的。我在节目《马尔科姆的一家》中，我真的很喜欢那个节目。但我每天，每天早上在办公室播出后，我都会进来，只是永远谈论办公室。他们就像，让我们开始做马尔科姆的故事吧。我就说，是的，是的，当然。
Did you see what happened on diversity day? So I was like, yeah, yeah, sure. Did you see what happened on diversity day? So I was a big fan. And I actually wrote a short story about a woman falls in love with the middle of a man. She works in quality control in a button factory and she sees the middle of people walking by window all day long and she puts all her hopes and dreams in the middle of this man. And oh my God, I love that. Jen, that is brilliant. It was so crazy. I had never written a short story before I wrote it.
你看到多样性日发生了什么吗？所以我说，是的，是的，当然。你看到多样性日发生了什么吗？所以我是一个大粉丝。我实际上写了一个关于一个女人爱上一个男人的中间的短篇小说。她在按钮工厂做质量控制，她整天看着人们的中间走过窗户，她把所有的希望和梦想都寄托在这个男人的中间。天哪，我喜欢那个。简，那太聪明了。这太疯狂了。在我写它之前，我从来没有写过短篇小说。
It took me forever to write it because I took me forever to sit down and figure out what I had to say. If any, did I have anything to say? And it kind of anyway, I wrote it. And then Suzanne Daniels, I found out that they have piles of scripts. The Daniels house has piles of scripts to the point where the kids have told me that they almost forget that their scripts, they think of them as furniture, like a coffee table somewhere to put their legs up. And Suzanne Daniels, I guess, grabbed my short story, probably thinner than the rest of the scripts on the pile and responded to it and gave it to Greg.
我写它花了我永远的时间，因为我花了我永远的时间坐下来弄清楚我要说什么。如果有的话，我有什么要说的吗？反正，我写了它。然后苏珊·丹尼尔斯，我发现他们有成堆的剧本。丹尼尔斯家有成堆的剧本，以至于孩子们告诉我，他们几乎忘记了那是剧本，他们认为它们是家具，就像某个地方的咖啡桌，可以把腿放上去。而苏珊·丹尼尔斯，我想，抓住了我的短篇小说，可能比堆里的其他剧本更薄，并回应了它，把它给了格雷格。
And then I met him at a coffee bean, had a meeting right before he was about to go to up front for season two and just probably begged to be on the show. I was really excited and just loved him, loved meeting him. And that's how it happened. Oh my gosh. That is such a fantastic story. Well, Jen, we have a question for you about,
然后我在咖啡豆遇到了他，在第二季发布会之前开了一个会，可能只是乞求加入节目。我真的很兴奋，只是爱他，喜欢见到他。这就是它是怎么发生的。天哪。那是一个如此精彩的故事。好吧，简，我们有一个关于你的问题，
obviously we're talking Benihana Christmas today. What was the inspiration for this episode? Do you remember how it came about? How you came to be the person to write it? Sort of the beginning of what was Benihana? The initial idea was Michael goes through a breakup and I can almost see myself leaping out of a chair at that moment when
显然我们今天在谈论贝尼哈纳圣诞节。这一集的灵感是什么？你还记得它是怎么来的吗？你是怎么成为写它的人的？某种程度上是贝尼哈纳的开始？最初的想法是迈克尔经历了一次分手，我几乎可以看到自己在那一刻从椅子上跳起来，当
I came from the room saying, I need to have this episode because I just felt like taking Michael through a breakup is just like having, how would a 14 year old boy deal with a breakup? You know, just kind of just the riding those waves for the first time. Has he ever been that close to a person to have, you know, to a romantic partner to have those waves so you can really take him to the point where he's lying on the floor? So I put in a little bit of 14 year old boy
我从房间里出来说，我需要有这一集，因为我只是觉得让迈克尔经历一次分手就像拥有，一个14岁的男孩会如何处理分手？你知道，只是那种第一次骑那些波浪。他曾经和一个那样亲近的人，你知道，和一个浪漫的伴侣有那些波浪，所以你可以真正带他到他躺在地板上的地步吗？所以我放了一点14岁男孩
and then a little bit of me, you know, listening to James Blunt goodbye my lover and breakups that I had. Like just, so there was a smush of the two of us, my version of Michael's stuff. And when I ended up leaving the office, which was devastatingly difficult to do, but I ended up telling Steve that I was leaving
然后是我的一点，你知道，听詹姆斯·布朗的再见我的爱人和我经历的分手。就像只是，所以有我们两个的混合，我版本的迈克尔的东西。当我最终离开办公室时，这非常困难，但我最终告诉史蒂夫我要离开
and I'll never forget his comment to me. He said, I think this is gonna be really difficult for you. And I said, yeah, no, definitely. But he's like, because I think you work a lot of your own stuff out through my character. I was like, there's this game that people play of like, who are they in the office? And I'm like, I can't be Pam or Angela or Phyllis. Like, I'm Michael. Michael thinks I'm Michael.
我永远不会忘记他对我的评论。他说，我认为这对你来说会非常困难。我说，是的，不，绝对。但他就像，因为我认为你通过我的角色解决了你自己的很多事情。我当时想，人们玩这种游戏，就像，他们在办公室里是谁？我就说，我不能是帕姆或安吉拉或菲利斯。就像，我是迈克尔。迈克尔认为我是迈克尔。
Steve was aware, Steve was aware when it was a Jen Salata script. Oh, well we're gonna work out some issues this week. Yes, yes. So I think that for the breakup, I put myself as being sort of delayed in that area and experiencing a breakup. I think my first breakup with a boyfriend was late,
史蒂夫知道，史蒂夫知道当它是简·萨拉塔的剧本时。哦，好吧，我们这周要解决一些问题。是的，是的。所以我认为对于分手，我把自己放在那个领域有点延迟，并经历了一次分手。我想我第一次和男朋友分手很晚，
you know, mid 20s, you know, just experiencing that. And then also just having, you know, just thinking of a young, a younger boy going through it. And I just left. I wanted it so badly. So I think I probably just wrestled someone to the ground for it. My God. Well, Jen, I would love to talk to you about the party planning committee versus the committee to plan parties. What the hell? You were saying on a previous podcast, Jenna, that I really am drawn to Angela and writing for Angela. And there was something I was starting to think about why that was beside just being brilliant. And it's so funny. And it's just fun to write for you. But I was thinking, I can't stand sometimes rules and bureaucracy and all of that stuff.
你知道，20多岁中期，你知道，只是经历那个。然后还有，你知道，只是想到一个年轻的，更年轻的男孩经历它。我只是离开了。我太想要它了。所以我认为我可能只是为了它把某人摔倒在地。天哪。好吧，简，我很想和你谈谈派对策划委员会与策划派对委员会。到底是怎么回事？你在之前的播客上说，珍娜，我真的被安吉拉吸引，并为安吉拉写作。有一些事情我开始思考为什么会那样，除了只是聪明。而且它太有趣了。而且为你写作很有趣。但我当时在想，我有时无法忍受规则和官僚主义以及所有那些东西。
And I feel like your character represented so many of those lines and things you can't do and limits. So somehow it was like cathartic for me to go deep in there and like have you push those lines with people. Comedy writers oftentimes want to push against authority and rules. And so you were were you represented that. So I just kind of love to give you that.
我觉得你的角色代表了许多那些界限和事情你不能做和限制。所以不知何故，这就像对我来说是一种宣泄，深入那里，让你与人们推动那些界限。喜剧编剧往往想推动反对权威和规则。所以你就是你代表了那个。所以我只是有点喜欢给你那个。
So then what do you do to your character? Threaten her with a rival party and just kind of up the stakes. A rival planning committee and up the stakes and have you kind of lose it. When you run out to try to get the permission from Dwight that the party needs to start now, it's just like the intensity with which you're clinging to the fact that you need to maintain the balance of your structure is like, I just delayed in that. I remember that scene.
那么你对你的角色做了什么？用竞争对手的派对威胁她，只是有点提高赌注。竞争对手的策划委员会，提高赌注，让你有点失去理智。当你跑出去试图从德怀特那里得到派对现在需要开始的许可时，就像你紧紧抓住你需要保持你的结构平衡的事实的那种强度，就像，我只是在那个方面延迟了。我记得那个场景。
I remember actually talking to you about the dialogue and you and Harold and I guess the first take I did it, maybe I didn't have that urgency. Like, and, and you guys like pulled me aside and you're like, no, like, like think like the building's on fire. Like I have an announcement, you know, and that kind of like stakes. And then Jen, while we're talking about this, I had a line where I said to Meredith as she's deciding which party to go to. I say,
我记得实际上和你谈论对话，你和哈罗德，我想我做的第一次拍摄，也许我没有那种紧迫感。就像，而且，你们就像把我拉到一边，你们就像，不，就像，像大楼着火了一样。就像我有一个公告，你知道，那种赌注。然后简，当我们谈论这个时，我有一句台词，我对梅雷迪思说，当她决定去哪个派对时。我说，
Meredith, like if you go to that party, you're going to be very, very sorry. And then Meredith is like, is that a threat? And I go, no, it's an invitation. I don't think I really got the joke on the first time I read it. And you're like, I really got the joke on the first time I read it. And you were like, Ange, will you like, maybe when you say it's an invitation, switch gears to like a smile? And I remember it changed the whole scene.
梅雷迪思，如果你去那个派对，你会非常，非常后悔。然后梅雷迪思就像，那是一个威胁吗？我就说，不，这是一个邀请。我不认为我第一次读它时真的明白了那个笑话。而你就像，我第一次读它时真的明白了那个笑话。你就像，安吉，你会，也许当你说是邀请时，切换档位到像一个微笑？我记得它改变了整个场景。
Like, I love that moment. That moment reminds me of in horror movies when like the deranged ex-boyfriend is like, let me in this house right now. I'm gonna be right here. And then there's like silence and he's like, Monica, I'd love to come inside. And you're like, whoa, that is super creepy me. That's scarier than the banging on the door.
就像，我喜欢那个时刻。那个时刻让我想起恐怖电影，当像精神错乱的前男友就像，现在让我进这所房子。我就要在这里。然后就像沉默，他就像，莫妮卡，我很乐意进来。你就像，哇，那超级令人毛骨悚然。那比敲门更可怕。
So that's when I watched that scene Angela, it's an invitation was like super unnerving. It was like what just happened? That was a note from Jen Salata just to peek into her brain. There's definitely an alternate reality where the office is a horror and Angela, there are moments where you're standing by the copier and then just jump out. But I feel like there's something where you get to see Angela's struggle of her real feelings in the episode because they leak out all over the place,
所以这就是当我观看那个场景安吉拉时，这是一个邀请，超级令人不安。就像刚才发生了什么？那是简·萨拉塔的一个笔记，只是窥视她的大脑。绝对有一个替代现实，办公室是一个恐怖，安吉拉，有时刻你站在复印机旁边，然后只是跳出来。但我感觉有一些东西，你能够看到安吉拉在这一集中真实感受的挣扎，因为它们到处泄漏，
but then the pop back to this is a work, this is an office, we have to be professional. So there's like, we get to see that like moment where you, where you, the threat comes out and then you know, this is office decorum, here I am as the next person. It's so creepy because we just saw what you really are or what part of you is. Or yeah. I love this storyline too because it serves that whole purpose. And then it also serves the purpose of putting Pam and Karen together and freaking Jim out. So that's why I, it's so rich with storyline.
但后来弹出回到这是一个工作，这是一个办公室，我们必须专业。所以就像，我们能够看到那个时刻，你，你，威胁出来了，然后你知道，这是办公室礼仪，我在这里作为下一个人。这太令人毛骨悚然了，因为我们刚刚看到了你真正是什么，或者你的一部分是什么。或者是的。我也喜欢这个故事情节，因为它服务于整个目的。然后它也服务于把帕姆和凯伦放在一起，让吉姆吓坏了。所以这就是为什么我，它如此丰富故事情节。
Should we head over to Benihana? Because Jen, we were not there that day that you shot in the restaurant. And there are so many delicious scenes. Delicious. I feel like that was a really good use of, is that like a metaphor? Because Benihana serves food? I don't know.
我们应该去贝尼哈纳吗？因为简，那天你在餐厅拍摄时我们不在那里。而且有这么多美味的场景。美味。我觉得那是对，那是一个隐喻吗？因为贝尼哈纳提供食物？我不知道。
Oh, well. I think that the idea of Benihana might've come up because it always cheered me up when I was a kid. If I'd been sick or if I got a good grade, we'd go to Benihana. And I remember they used to like fling shrimp in your mouth. I heard that when I was doing research for this episode that they stopped doing that.
哦，好吧。我认为贝尼哈纳的想法可能出现是因为当我还是个孩子时，它总是让我振作起来。如果我生病了或者我得到了一个好成绩，我们会去贝尼哈纳。我记得他们过去喜欢把虾扔进你的嘴里。我听说当我为这一集做研究时，他们停止了那样做。
I think that they were worried about it being dangerous. And so- Flinging hot shrimp across a restaurant. Yes. But Jen, I love to know like how Benihana was like part of your childhood memory because our youngest son, when he turned eight, the one thing he wanted to do was go to Bini Hana.
我想他们担心这很危险。所以- 在餐厅里扔热虾。是的。但简，我喜欢知道像贝尼哈纳是如何成为你童年记忆的一部分的，因为我们最小的儿子，当他八岁时，他想做的一件事就是去贝尼哈纳。
Oh yes! Well it's like... That was like our eight year old's birthday. It's dinner and a show! I remember, so there was a scene where Dwight talks about the knife that the chef is using and how, oh I bet you're bummed that you want this other knife and the chef is saying, no, no, this knife is better, Dwight, You don't know what the best knife is. And I kind of put this together when I was rewatching the episode. But when we were there, there
哦是的！好吧，它就像... 那就像我们八岁孩子的生日。这是晚餐和表演！我记得，所以有一个场景，德怀特谈论厨师正在使用的刀，以及如何，哦，我打赌你很沮丧你想要这把其他的刀，厨师说，不，不，这把刀更好，德怀特，你不知道什么是最好的刀。当我重看这一集时，我有点把这个放在一起。但当我们去那里时，那里
was a problem making the onion volcano. So that was sort of the biggest holdup of the day. The chef couldn't make the onion volcano and then they brought in another chef to make the onion volcano. We couldn't get an onion volcano off the ground. And I think we had one of the more celebrated onion volcano chefs there. And what immediately happened to me, even though I wrote the scene with Dwight talking about knives, is I was like, well, maybe the is the oven hot enough? Are you sure that the right positioning of the onion? They know onion volcanoes. I don't
有一个制作洋葱火山的问题。所以那是一天中最大的阻碍。厨师做不出洋葱火山，然后他们带了另一个厨师来做洋葱火山。我们无法让洋葱火山离开地面。而且我认为我们在那里有最著名的洋葱火山厨师之一。而且我立即发生了什么，即使我写了德怀特谈论刀的场景，我当时想，好吧，也许烤箱够热吗？你确定洋葱的正确位置吗？他们知道洋葱火山。我不知道
know onion volcanoes, but we were desperately trying to get this. And so all of us were sitting around giving notes to a person who was already in a difficult time making the onion volcano, trying to get help. You know, how can we help this? So secret little fun fact, the steam from the onion was added in post because we never... Oh my gosh! The volcano never erupted on the day. There was, I think, a fluttering of smoke that came out after, I want to say, hours of trying to get this off the ground. And I think it was Dean Holland who was editing the episode who's like, here's what we're going to do. We're going to add some, we're going to add
洋葱火山，但我们拼命试图得到这个。所以我们所有人都坐在周围给一个已经在制作洋葱火山困难时期的人提供笔记，试图得到帮助。你知道，我们怎么能帮助这个？所以秘密的小趣事，洋葱的蒸汽是在后期添加的，因为我们从来没有... 哦天哪！火山那天从来没有爆发。有，我想，几个小时试图让这个离开地面后出来的一阵烟雾。而且我认为是迪恩·霍兰德在编辑这一集，他就像，这是我们要做的。我们要添加一些，我们要添加
some smoke to the onion. We can do this. And I, I can just imagine my past Jen crying at that moment of relief because the onion sputtering would not lift up a heartbroken Michael and, you know, we needed that onion to do its part. Yes. Yes. Oh my gosh, I love that story so much. So Jen, now we want to talk about the storyline with the Benihana waitresses and how Michael can't tell them apart. And I know we traded emails about this. Even though we're saying, Michael, you should know better what you're doing is wrong. Is it even right to put that storyline out there?
一些烟雾到洋葱。我们可以做到。而且我，我可以想象我过去的简在那个解脱的时刻哭泣，因为洋葱的喷溅无法举起一个心碎的迈克尔，而且，你知道，我们需要那个洋葱做它的部分。是的。是的。哦天哪，我太喜欢那个故事了。所以简，现在我们想谈谈与贝尼哈纳女服务员的故事情节，以及迈克尔如何无法区分她们。而且我知道我们为此交换了电子邮件。即使我们说，迈克尔，你应该知道得更好，你在做什么是错的。把那个故事情节放出来甚至是对的吗？
Can you share your reaction to rewatching it? You know, it's like I feel conflicted about the whole like there was this like Archie Bunker, Michael Scott, David Brent's thing that we would make a joke that this is clearly inappropriate. But some of that stuff is just not appropriate, even if it's being made a joke fun of. And some is. And I don't know where some of the line is, but what is offensive? What is going to hurt somebody? What is making fun of a character who does this? And is that even OK? Where's the line for that?
你能分享你重看它的反应吗？你知道，就像我感到矛盾，关于整个就像有这个就像阿奇·邦克，迈克尔·斯科特，大卫·布伦特的事情，我们会开个玩笑，这显然是不合适的。但其中一些东西只是不合适，即使它被开玩笑。而且有些是。而且我不知道界限在哪里，但什么是冒犯？什么会伤害某人？什么是在取笑一个做这个的角色？而且那甚至可以吗？那的界限在哪里？
We're constantly growing and have to understand, even if our intention was to do something to show how ridiculous this behavior is at the time, how does that portrayal come across and is that affecting people? And just taking it all in and just trying to educate myself as much as I can about how what we put out there affects people. Yeah, absolutely.
我们不断成长，必须理解，即使我们的意图是做一些事情来展示这种行为在当时是多么荒谬，那种描绘是如何出现的，这是否在影响人们？而且只是吸收这一切，只是试图尽可能多地教育自己关于我们放出的东西如何影响人们。是的，绝对。
I feel like as a creative community, we need to learn and reevaluate how we tell stories. Yeah, and like you said, Jen, how those stories affect people. Yeah. Yeah. All right, Jen, well, before you go, can we ask you just a couple of quick little questions
我觉得作为一个创意社区，我们需要学习并重新评估我们如何讲故事。是的，就像你说的，简，那些故事如何影响人们。是的。是的。好吧，简，在你走之前，我们可以问你几个快速的小问题吗
about this episode? OK, first of all, everyone wants to know, is there a significance to Jim and Karen both giving one another a copy of Bridget Jones' diary? Is there a story there? As far as I remember, it was that they saw it together. I don't think they were fans of it. And they kind of gave it to each other
关于这一集？好的，首先，每个人都想知道，吉姆和凯伦都给对方一份《BJ单身日记》有什么意义吗？那里有一个故事吗？据我所知，是他们一起看了它。我不认为他们是它的粉丝。而且他们有点给对方
as sort of a joke gift. I remember we were talking about, they wouldn't be giving each other a really significant gift, right? At this point, it's not like a really big gift, but at the same time, it should be a gift that if Pam is watching, will feel like, oh god, they're on the same wavelength. So it was like, you don't want him to give her jewelry, but at the same time,
作为一种玩笑礼物。我记得我们在谈论，他们不会给对方一份非常有意义的礼物，对吧？在这一点上，这不是一份非常大的礼物，但同时，它应该是一份礼物，如果帕姆在看，会觉得，哦天哪，他们在同一个波长上。所以就像，你不想让他给她珠宝，但同时，
you don't want just two different gifts where it's just A for just the efficiency of a script where they have to both be explained. Why does this mean something? Why does this mean something? So it was a quick way to sort of say they're on a similar wavelength but it's not a real serious gift there was a debate between Mindy and Mike about that movie because Mindy would talk about her classic comedy movies and this is more about her age she you know would say Bridget Jones is like a classic comedy and Mike would probably talk about, I can't even remember the examples of the
你不想只是两份不同的礼物，只是为了剧本的效率，它们都必须被解释。为什么这有什么意义？为什么这有什么意义？所以这是一种快速的方式，可以说他们在相似的波长上，但这不是一份非常严肃的礼物，明迪和迈克之间关于那部电影有一场辩论，因为明迪会谈论她经典的喜剧电影，而这更多是关于她的年龄，她，你知道，会说《BJ单身日记》就像一部经典的喜剧，而迈克可能会谈论，我甚至不记得例子，
apartment or like just, right? So Mindy got Mike a Bridget Jones diary poster and signed it and Mike hung it on his wall. So I think the fact that it was a bit of a joke between Mike and Mindy, it ended up getting that was the specific that we use. So it wasn't just, uh, let's make fun of a movie that's super popular and great. Angela, you wanted to ask about karaoke. I did. I wanted to ask you, Jen, how you guys decided on the songs that each character would sing.
公寓或者就像，对吧？所以明迪给了迈克一张《BJ单身日记》海报，并签了名，迈克把它挂在他的墙上。所以我认为这是一个在迈克和明迪之间有点玩笑的事实，它最终得到了我们使用的具体内容。所以它不仅仅是，呃，让我们取笑一部超级流行和伟大的电影。安吉拉，你想问关于卡拉OK的事。我问了。我想问你，简，你们是如何决定每个角色会唱的歌的。
Kevin sings, you ought to know by Alanis Morissette. Michael and Andy sing, your body is a wonderland, John Mayer. Kelly sings, we belong, which is hilarious by Pat Benatar. Creed sings his own song, spinnin' and realin'. And then of course Dwight sings Lady by Styx. Yes, so, all right. I remember we belong definitely me. I came up with that because I, as soon as I like a guy,
凯文唱，阿兰妮斯·莫里塞特的《你应该知道》。迈克尔和安迪唱，约翰·梅尔的《你的身体是仙境》。凯利唱，帕特·贝纳塔的《我们属于》，这太搞笑了。克里德唱他自己的歌，《旋转和卷轴》。然后当然德怀特唱斯汀克斯的《女士》。是的，所以，好吧。我记得我们属于绝对是我。我想出那个是因为我，一旦我喜欢上一个家伙，
I would start singing that in the shower. That is me. That is where me and the Kelly Kapoor character collide. However, I am 99% sure it was Mindy that said, we belong together, Ryan. Like I did not have that in my draft. I just had her singing. It's genius.
我就会开始在淋浴时唱那个。那是我。那是我和凯利·卡普尔角色碰撞的地方。然而，我99%确定是明迪说，我们属于一起，瑞安。就像我没有在我的草稿里有那个。我只是让她唱歌。这是天才。
It makes the moment. It's so good. I just looked up. I had in my writer's first draft, Kevin, singing, one second please, Mo Money Mo Problems by Notorious B.I.G. instead of Alon Smoresett. So somehow during the rewrite process, it became you want to know which is just fantastic where he just goes forward at the end. I watched
它成就了那个时刻。太好了。我刚刚查了。我在我的编剧第一稿里有，凯文，唱歌，请等一秒，臭名昭著B.I.G.的《更多钱更多问题》而不是阿兰妮斯·莫里塞特。所以不知何故在重写过程中，它变成了《你应该知道》，这太棒了，他在最后只是向前走。我看了
that scene and I noticed I don't know if it's Jim or if it's John where you see him laughing smiling at Brian. It feels like he's breaking, but I don't, I agree. Never off on the censure. Oh no, I wrote it in a time code and everything. He's clearly breaking. You can see his cheeks bulging and that's why he doesn't turn around. He's like fixated on Kevin because John is breaking.
那个场景，我注意到我不知道是吉姆还是约翰，你看到他在笑，对着布莱恩微笑。感觉他要崩溃了，但我不知道，我同意。从来没有在审查上。哦不，我写了一个时间码和一切。他显然要崩溃了。你可以看到他的脸颊鼓起来，这就是为什么他不转身。他就像盯着凯文，因为约翰要崩溃了。
That's amazing. And I do remember we wanted Creed to sing one of his own songs. We just thought that was incredible. Yeah. Like just what a cool opportunity. How often do we have that? Like dude was in a band.
那太神奇了。而且我确实记得我们想让克里德唱他自己的一首歌。我们只是认为那太不可思议了。是的。就像，多么酷的机会。我们多久有一次？就像伙计在一个乐队里。
He was in a band. He's phenomenal. I was gonna say one thing that's in another song thing, but not for here. I wrote a joke where Michael says, I got two tickets to paradise. He says pack your bags. We leave the day after tomorrow.
他在一个乐队里。他太棒了。我本来要说一件事，在另一首歌里，但不是为了这里。我写了一个笑话，迈克尔说，我有两张去天堂的票。他说收拾你的行李。我们后天离开。
And at the sound mix, I found out from Kent that that was a $60,000 joke. Ah! I was like, it's a fine joke. Like, none of my jokes I've ever written have been a $60,000 joke. But I remember not so long after that, we had some of our music budget pulled away from us.
在声音混合时，我从肯特那里发现那是一个6万美元的笑话。啊！我当时想，这是一个很好的笑话。就像，我写过的任何笑话都没有成为6万美元的笑话。但我记得在那之后不久，我们的一些音乐预算被拿走了。
And I can't help but think, I mean, I was sitting at the mix and had no idea that because he sang that song, that song had to be cleared and that joke was $60,000. Jen Salata, you are such a delight. I just enjoy you so much and we just want you to come back as many times as you will, please. Oh, I'm in. It's so much fun. It's so much fun. All right, Jen. Thank you so much.
而且我忍不住想，我的意思是，我坐在混合处，根本不知道因为他唱了那首歌，那首歌必须被清除，那个笑话是6万美元。简·萨拉塔，你真是太令人高兴了。我只是非常享受你，我们只是想让你回来尽可能多次，请。哦，我加入。这太有趣了。这太有趣了。好吧，简。非常感谢你。
Thank you so much, Jen. There's regular cold. And then there's the mountains are blue cold. Mountain cold refreshment. Coors light. The chill choice. Celebrate responsibly. Must be legal drinking age.
非常感谢你，简。有普通的冷。然后有山是蓝色的冷。山冷清爽。库尔斯淡啤。寒冷的选择。负责任地庆祝。必须是法定饮酒年龄。
As a BMO Eclipse Visa Infinite Card Holder, you don't just earn points. Ahem. You earn five times the points. On the must haves, like groceries and gas, and little extras like takeout and ride share. So you build your points faster. And then you can redeem your points
作为BMO日食Visa无限卡持卡人，你不仅仅赚取积分。咳咳。你赚取五倍的积分。在必需品上，比如杂货和汽油，以及小额外的东西，比如外卖和拼车。所以你更快地建立你的积分。然后你可以兑换你的积分
on things like travel and more. And we could all use a vacation. Apply now and get up to 60,000 points. So many points! For more info, visit bemo.com slash eclipse. Visit us today. Sensing conditions apply. Whoop whoop!
在旅行等事情上。而且我们都可以使用假期。现在申请并获得高达60,000积分。这么多积分！欲了解更多信息，请访问bemo.com斜杠日食。今天访问我们。感应条件适用。呜呜！
Stop. Do you know how fast you were going? I'm gonna have to write you a ticket to my new movie, The Naked Gun. Liam Neeson. Buy your tickets now and get a free chili dog. Chili dog not included. The Naked Gun tickets on sale now, August 1st. Okay, we are back.
停下。你知道你开得有多快吗？我得给你开一张去我的新电影《白头神探》的票。利亚姆·尼森。现在买你的票并获得一个免费的辣椒热狗。不包括辣椒热狗。《白头神探》票现在发售，8月1日。好的，我们回来了。
Let's break down the rest of this episode. We are at the hibachi table, and Dwight has decided that he knows more about knives than the Benihana chef. Yeah. He's sort of like, ooh, is that an akiri? And the chef is like, no, it's a soba. And Dwight's like, oh, I bet you wish you had an akiri.
让我们解析这一集的其余部分。我们在铁板烧桌旁，德怀特决定他比贝尼哈纳厨师更了解刀。是的。他有点像，哦，那是阿基里吗？厨师就像，不，它是荞麦面。德怀特就像，哦，我打赌你希望你有一把阿基里。
And the chef's like, actually, this is better for large quantities. Yeah. And Dw chef's like, actually, this is better for large quantities. Yeah. And Dwight's like, I'm not sure. And then I, I wrote down a restaurant lady sass. I love this moment so much. And the actress's name is Annie Surtick. And she says, I think he would know. And then they look at each other, they like glare at each other, but I loved the way she delivered that line. Also want to give a shout out to the chef in the scene who I believe was a real Benihana chef. That's what Kent told us. I also noticed this is his only credit on IMDb. He also really knew what he was doing. And his name is Chatri Yovisitzak. Good job schooling
厨师就像，实际上，这更适合大量。是的。德怀特就像，我不确定。然后我，我写下了一个餐厅女士的傲慢。我太喜欢这个时刻了。而且女演员的名字是安妮·瑟蒂克。她说，我想他会知道。然后他们看着对方，他们就像瞪着对方，但我喜欢她传达那句台词的方式。也想给场景中的厨师大喊大叫，我相信他是一个真正的贝尼哈纳厨师。这就是肯特告诉我们的。我也注意到这是他在IMDb上的唯一信用。他也真的知道他在做什么。而且他的名字是查特里·约维西扎克。干得好，教育
Dwight Chatri. Exactly. Well, there is a deleted scene that happens right here, Jenna. And it's so good. Michael sneaks off to call Carol and he asks her what he did wrong. And he's on the phone for a long time. And then he says, Well, all right, could you tell me something that I did right? And then she hangs up. Oh, no. Oh, oh, that's crushing. But just watching Steve as Michael play the moment where he's listening to her rant and he's like, okay, well, did I do anything right?
德怀特查特里。正是。好吧，这里发生了一个删除的场景，珍娜。而且它太好了。迈克尔溜走去给卡罗尔打电话，他问她他做错了什么。而且他在电话上很长时间。然后他说，好吧，好吧，你能告诉我我做对的一件事吗？然后她挂断了。哦，不。哦，哦，那太令人崩溃了。但只是看着史蒂夫作为迈克尔扮演他听她咆哮的时刻，他就像，好的，好吧，我做对什么了吗？
It was really funny. After that phone call, is that when he would go back to the table and then Andy's trying to cheer him up? Yes, exactly. And then Andy's like, let's get around to drinks going, you know, and he tells him about this smoking volcano onion that's going to come. So that he comes back from the call really dejected. Ah, and this is what we talked about in the interview with Jen about the the steam from
真的很有趣。在那通电话之后，他回到桌边，安迪试图让他振作起来，是那个时候吗？是的，没错。然后安迪说，我们来点饮料吧，你知道的，他还告诉他那个即将上桌的冒烟火山洋葱。所以他接完电话回来时真的很沮丧。啊，这就是我们在采访珍时谈到的关于……的蒸汽。
the onion. I tracked it. It's 21 minutes, 44 seconds. If you wanna see a real good shot of some fake onion steam. I tracked it too. Look, I have my time code and everything. I got really excited. Okay, where are we?
洋葱的蒸汽。我追踪到了。是在21分44秒。如果你想看一个非常好的假洋葱蒸汽镜头。我也追踪到了。看，我有时间码和一切。我真的很兴奋。好了，我们讲到哪了？
Oh, well, we're back. We're back at Scranton. And Pam and Karen have announced that their party is starting. And this is when Angela starts to spiral out. And she's like, I have a very important announcement. And she's trying to make sure her party starts before theirs. Yes.
哦，对了，我们回来了。我们回到了斯克兰顿。帕姆和凯伦宣布她们的派对开始了。就在这时，安吉拉开始失控了。她说，我有一个非常重要的公告。她试图确保她的派对在她们的派对之前开始。是的。
And then this is when Angela calls Dwight. And she announces that her party has started early. And it's also here. I tracked this, Angela, because we talked about this with Jen as well. At 20 minutes, minutes 50 seconds this is that scene where you say it's an invitation yeah it's not was right there it's an invitation that's that's when you see how Angela Martin would be in a horror movie well also in this scene we didn't talk about with Jen, at 23 minutes 20 seconds, there is a really good shot of my gray tights that I'm wearing instead of pantyhose.
然后就在这时，安吉拉给德怀特打了电话。她宣布她的派对提前开始了。也是在这里。我追踪到了这一点，安吉拉，因为我们也和珍谈过这个。在20分50秒，就是那个你说“这是邀请函”的场景，没错，就在那儿，那是邀请函，那就是你看到安吉拉·马丁在恐怖电影里会是什么样的时候。嗯，在这个场景里，我们没和珍谈到的是，在23分20秒，有一个非常好的镜头，拍到了我穿的灰色连裤袜，而不是长筒丝袜。
That's all. That's all. Well, Jenna, I have something that I got really excited about. This is a great background catch for my folks that love the background like I do. I mean, I froze it. I took a picture of it.
就是这样。就是这样。好吧，珍娜，我有一些让我非常兴奋的事情。对于像我一样喜欢背景细节的粉丝来说，这是一个很棒的背景发现。我是说，我把它定格了。我拍了张照片。
I'm very excited. At 23 minutes 10 seconds, in the deep background, Andy's screen and accounting looks like someone was surfing the internet. Zoom in. So then at 23 minutes, 28 seconds, there is a picture of a cat with a cowboy hat screen saver on Andy's computer.
我非常兴奋。在23分10秒，在深背景里，安迪在会计部的屏幕看起来好像有人在上网。放大看。然后在23分28秒，安迪的电脑屏幕保护程序是一张戴着牛仔帽的猫的照片。
I want to say, Angela, this same thing happens in the cold open. When Dwight comes in with the goose, I am surfing the internet. And then the next shot when you see me at my desk, I have changed it to a screen saver. We were really surfing the internet in this episode, clearly. What happened? We were just like the internet in this episode, clearly. What happened?
我想说，安吉拉，同样的事情也发生在冷开场里。当德怀特带着鹅进来时，我正在上网。然后下一个镜头，当你看到我在办公桌前时，我已经把它换成了屏幕保护程序。显然，我们在这一集里确实在上网。发生了什么？我们显然就像这一集里的互联网一样。发生了什么？
We were just there, paying our bills and shopping. So now, Angela has announced that her party is starting. Do you know who the very first person to go to the other party is? Stanley. He stands there for a long time and looks back and forth and then picks Karen and Pam's party, and he gives a look to camera.
我们当时只是在那里付账单和购物。所以现在，安吉拉宣布她的派对开始了。你知道第一个去参加另一个派对的人是谁吗？斯坦利。他站在那里看了很久，来回看了看，然后选择了凯伦和帕姆的派对，他还对着镜头看了一眼。
Is this Stanley's first direct look to camera. Is this Stanley's first like direct look to camera? Yes, I think it is. Yeah, I think it is. I also want to say Stanley, what were you mulling over? I mean, what took so long? There was there was a chance you were ever going to go to Angela's party? A lot of suspense. Well, he might have to put up with Phyllis, you know, because you know Phyllis is going to my party. So maybe it was more layered of a decision. All right, so here's a breakdown of who goes to Karen and Pam's party.
这是斯坦利第一次直接看镜头吗？这是斯坦利第一次直接看镜头吗？是的，我想是。是的，我想是。我还想说斯坦利，你在琢磨什么呢？我是说，怎么花了那么长时间？你真的有可能会去参加安吉拉的派对吗？真是悬念重重。好吧，他可能得忍受菲利斯，你知道的，因为你知道菲利斯要去我的派对。所以这可能是一个更复杂的决定。好了，这是去参加凯伦和帕姆派对的人员名单。
You have Stanley, and you have Kelly, and Ryan, and Meredith. And then later we see that Daryl,l and Roy and Creed are all there as well. The only people that go to Angela's party are Hannah who's by the way really snarky she's so snarky and Kevin and Phyllis. Yeah but then Kevin is going to leave your party and come to my party. I know I know. We'll get to it. Something I want to point out to everyone is that there is this huge Pam, Karen, Angela stare off, right? Yeah. Yeah.
有斯坦利，还有凯利、瑞安和梅雷迪斯。后来我们看到达里尔、罗伊和克里德也都在那里。唯一去参加安吉拉派对的人是汉娜——顺便说一下，她真的很刻薄，她太刻薄了——还有凯文和菲利斯。是的，但后来凯文要离开你的派对，来我的派对。我知道，我知道。我们稍后再说。我想向大家指出的一点是，有一场巨大的帕姆、凯伦和安吉拉的对视，对吧？是的。是的。
It is for nine seconds. That's nine seconds of dead air time. It starts at 24 minutes, 30 seconds. It goes to 24 minutes, 39 seconds. And I don't know why, but I wrote, that's longer than you have to stay on a bull in like professional bull riding. You get eight seconds to stay on a bull. We stared at each other longer than you have to stay on a bull in professional bull riding.
持续了九秒钟。那是九秒钟的死寂时间。从24分30秒开始。一直到24分39秒。我不知道为什么，但我写道，这比你在职业骑牛比赛中必须坚持的时间还要长。你只有八秒钟的时间留在牛背上。我们盯着对方看的时间比你在职业骑牛比赛中必须坚持的时间还要长。
Well, Angela, I loved that you tracked our stare in bull riding seconds. I think that should be a new standard on our show. You're welcome, you're welcome. Is it longer or shorter than a bull ride? Well, Angela, this leads me into your talking head. It's so wonderful. You explain that you don't back down. It's a source of pride.
好吧，安吉拉，我喜欢你用骑牛秒数来追踪我们的对视。我认为这应该成为我们节目的一项新标准。不客气，不客气。是比骑牛时间长还是短？好吧，安吉拉，这让我想到了你的独白。太棒了。你解释说你从不退缩。这是一种自豪的源泉。
And in fact, you have not talked to your sister in 16 years because of an argument that you guys got into. You're that good. You don't even remember what the argument was about. Yeah. She's really proud of it. She's proud that she hasn't spoken to her sister. She doesn't even know why anymore, but she's not making that phone call.
事实上，你已经16年没和你姐姐说话了，因为你们之间发生过一次争吵。你就是这么厉害。你甚至不记得争吵的内容是什么了。是的。她真的很以此为荣。她为自己没和姐姐说话而感到自豪。她甚至不知道为什么了，但她就是不打那个电话。
Well, we had a fan question. Okay. Hannah Mac, Lindsay Neame, Ali Burke, Veronica Ramirez, and Jesse Clark all said, Angela says that her sister was her best friend, but they haven't spoken for 16 years. But then later, her sister Rachel appears at the end of the series in her bridal shower, where Angela describes them as being very close. Is this the same sister? Okay, I don't know what you have to say about it, Angela, but I have some facts about it. What is your answer? No, no, I want to hear your facts. I looked it up in the show Bible. And here's what it said. Season five, episode 13, it is revealed that Angela has several sisters.
好吧，我们有一个粉丝提问。好的。汉娜·麦克、琳赛·尼姆、阿里·伯克、维罗妮卡·拉米雷斯和杰西·克拉克都说，安吉拉说她姐姐是她最好的朋友，但她们已经16年没说话了。但后来，她姐姐瑞秋在剧集结尾出现在她的新娘送礼会上，安吉拉形容她们关系非常亲密。这是同一个姐姐吗？好吧，我不知道你对此有什么要说的，安吉拉，但我有一些关于它的事实。你的回答是什么？不，不，我想听听你的事实。我在剧集圣经里查过了。上面是这样写的：第五季第13集，揭示了安吉拉有几个姐妹。
So later at the wedding, we're referring to one of her sisters, Rachel. Although in the wedding, it sort of implies that you only have one sister again, so it is a little ambiguous. What's your story here, Ange? I always assumed that I had several siblings. You know, I had that line in the Martin family we say looks like someone took the slow train to Philly. I just assumed there was more than just me and my parents, you know?
所以后来在婚礼上，我们指的是她的一个姐妹，瑞秋。虽然在婚礼上，这似乎又暗示你只有一个姐妹，所以有点模棱两可。你这里有什么故事，安吉？我一直以为我有好几个兄弟姐妹。你知道，我有那句台词：“在马丁家族，我们说看起来就像有人坐了去费城的慢车。”我只是以为除了我和我父母之外还有别人，你知道吗？
So I assumed I had more siblings and that the sibling at my wedding was not the one that I haven't spoken to. Because unless she reached out to me, I'm still not talking to her. Well, you made that clear in your talking head. Yes. That's for sure. All right. So should we go back to Benny Hanna? Now, Michael is getting wasted and he is going to steal some steak from a stranger's plate because he claims it's family style.
所以我以为我有更多的兄弟姐妹，而且我婚礼上的那个姐妹不是我没说话的那个。因为除非她主动联系我，否则我还是不会和她说话。好吧，你在独白里说得很清楚了。是的。那是肯定的。好了。那我们回到贝尼哈纳餐厅吧。现在，迈克尔喝醉了，他要从陌生人的盘子里偷一些牛排，因为他声称这是家庭式的。
And Jim is like, no, it's not. Jenna, this brings me to, I think we need to start tracking some drinks. Okay? I love it. How could we do this podcast without you tracking drinks? It's your favorite thing. Truly, it's like my purpose in life is to track these ridiculous things. So I'm gonna take us back for a moment,
吉姆说，不，不是。珍娜，这让我想起，我觉得我们需要开始追踪一些饮料了。好吗？我喜欢。没有你追踪饮料，我们怎么做这个播客？这是你最喜欢的事情。真的，追踪这些荒谬的事情就像是我的人生目标。所以我先带我们回到片刻之前，
but at 19 minutes, 40 seconds, that's when Andy orders the first round, right? OK. Michael's come back from this phone call that we didn't know about. And now Andy orders the first round. Andy, Michael, and Dwight all get these cocktails. Jim gets what looks like to be like a Coca-Cola of some kind.
但在19分40秒，那是安迪点第一轮酒的时候，对吧？好的。迈克尔从那通我们不知道的电话中回来。现在安迪点了第一轮。安迪、迈克尔和德怀特都点了这些鸡尾酒。吉姆点的看起来像是某种可口可乐。
It's like a brown-looking soda. For my own peace of mind, I'm going to make Jim their designated driver. Go on. Oh, he 100% is. Okay. And then at 21 minutes, 25 seconds, you see Michael like downing his, he's like slamming it back. Then at 21 minutes, 31 seconds, Cindy is giving them a second round. Now she just gives it to Andy and Michael. I don't know about Dwight. But at 25 minutes, 8 seconds, there's two more drinks in front of Michael and Andy. So by my tracking, I think they've had at least three. Okay, so now we have the scene with the waitress where Andy is asking the waitress to close
那是一种棕色的苏打水。为了我自己的安心，我要让吉姆当他们的指定司机。继续。哦，他百分之百是。好的。然后在21分25秒，你看到迈克尔在喝他的酒，他像是在猛灌。然后在21分31秒，辛迪给了他们第二轮。现在她只给了安迪和迈克尔。我不知道德怀特有没有。但在25分8秒，迈克尔和安迪面前又多了两杯酒。所以根据我的追踪，我想他们至少喝了三杯。好的，现在我们到了服务员的场景，安迪要求服务员闭上
her eyes and imagine her dream house and then describe it to him. And Dwight can't hear any of this. So he asked Jim to explain what's happening. Jim says, oh, she's trying to describe how to butcher a dead goose, but she can't figure it out. So then Dwight chimes in and it ends up being very creepy and random. And can I just say I was in food service. Guys, stop being pervy and weird. Yeah, just be cordial. Be cordial. I mean, when they asked her to close her eyes, like, did you see how many tables she had?
眼睛，想象她的梦想家园，然后描述给他听。德怀特听不到这一切。所以他让吉姆解释发生了什么。吉姆说，哦，她正在试图描述如何宰杀一只死鹅，但她想不出来。于是德怀特插话了，结果变得非常令人毛骨悚然且随意。我能说我曾经在餐饮业工作过吗？伙计们，别再那么猥琐和奇怪了。是的，保持礼貌。保持礼貌。我是说，当他们让她闭上眼睛时，你看到她有多少桌要照顾了吗？
She is so busy. She's probably in the weeds, getting everything out to all these tables. She doesn't have time to like humor some guy who wants to flirt. You're at a restaurant with chefs doing a whole food show for you.
她太忙了。她可能忙得不可开交，要把所有东西送到这些桌子上。她没有时间去迎合一个想调情的家伙。你们在一家有厨师为你们表演全套美食秀的餐厅里。
That's your entertainment. Leave your waitress alone. In general, leave your waitresses alone. Come on, everybody. Oh, but before we move on from this table scene, I want to give a shout out to the guest actress who plays the woman at the table. Yes, Annie Sertik, who gives Dwight so much sass.
那是你们的娱乐活动。别打扰你们的服务员。总的来说，别打扰你们的服务员。拜托，大家。哦，但在我们离开这个餐桌场景之前，我想向扮演餐桌旁那位女士的客串女演员致敬。是的，安妮·瑟蒂克，她给了德怀特很多反击。
Yes. Guys,ertik, who gives Dwight so much sass. Yes. Guys, she's amazing. I feel like she's only got the one line to Dwight, but her expressions and all of her reactions during the scene are so great. And she is a company member at the Groundlings. She's had recurring roles on Silicon Valley and Two Broke Girls.
是的。伙计们，她太棒了。我觉得她对德怀特只有一句台词，但她在场景中的表情和所有反应都太棒了。她是Groundlings剧团的成员。她在《硅谷》和《破产姐妹》中都有常驻角色。
And I did a deep dive on her IMDB, and I found this little interesting bit of trivia, Angela. the groundlings. She's had recurring roles on Silicon Valley and Two Broke Girls. And I did a deep dive on her IMDB and I found this little interesting bit of trivia, Angela. She was on Curb Your Enthusiasm where she played quote unquote buffet woman. And then she was on Cougar Town playing female chef. I just thought it was interesting that she's had three guest roles involving food. I'm also really envious that she got to play buffet woman because that's the role of my dreams. Yes, exactly. All right, we're back now at the parties. Angela's is not going well. It's pretty boring. Phyllis is like desperate to get out of this party. She really is one of my favorite
我深入研究了她的IMDb，我发现了这个有趣的小花絮，安吉拉。她在《抑制热情》中扮演了所谓的“自助餐女士”。然后她在《熟女镇》中扮演了“女厨师”。我只是觉得她有三个涉及食物的客串角色很有趣。我也真的很羡慕她能扮演自助餐女士，因为那是我的梦想角色。是的，没错。好了，我们现在回到派对上。安吉拉的派对进行得不顺利。很无聊。菲利斯简直迫不及待地想离开这个派对。她真的是我最喜欢的
things in this whole episode. Her yearning to be at the other party is so brilliant. Phyllis is so brilliant. And there's a deleted scene that's great that really would have amplified this. She pours herself like a drink and it's like ginger ale and she says, oh, there's not a lot of fizz in this. And she starts to make her way to the door and I'm like, no, no, no. She goes, I might should get some more ginger ale. And I'm like, no, no, no.
这一整集里的事情之一。她渴望去参加另一个派对的样子太精彩了。菲利斯太精彩了。有一个很棒的删减片段，真的会放大这一点。她给自己倒了一杯饮料，像是姜汁汽水，她说，哦，这里面没什么气泡。她开始往门口走，我心想，不，不，不。她说，我可能应该再去拿点姜汁汽水。我心想，不，不，不。
And I block her from leaving. I was like, I'll go get it. You stay. That is amazing. But her reaction when she pours it and she's like, there's not a lot of fizz. It's like, you see her plotting to get out of the conference room. Well, I also quite enjoyed in the scene,
我挡住她不让她离开。我说，我去拿。你待着。这太神奇了。但她倒酒时的反应，她说“没什么气泡”，就像是你看到她在策划如何离开会议室一样。好吧，我也很喜欢这个场景，
Hannah, if you look at her in the background, she is like really examining the napkins. She is giving your napkins like the third degree. I'm sorry she's not going to stick around longer. Well, we'll get to that in future episodes. Yes. All right, well, Pam and Karen's party is a big hit, except the karaoke machine won't work because they don't have the right cord. But don't worry, because Darryl is gonna go get his keyboard.
汉娜，如果你看背景里的她，她真的在检查餐巾纸。她正在对你的餐巾纸进行严厉盘问。很抱歉她没能多待一会儿。好吧，我们会在以后的剧集里讲到。是的。好了，帕姆和凯伦的派对很成功，除了卡拉OK机因为没有合适的线而无法工作。但别担心，因为达里尔要去拿他的键盘。
And then there's this scene that I absolutely love as Darryl walks past the conference room. He's like, hey, when you're done with your meeting, there's a party in the break room. But it's the way Craig says it, because Craig is like, hey, guys, when you get done with your meeting, it's like he doesn't quite know what to call it. What are they doing? Meeting? You should come to the break room because we're having an actual party. And I love it. And that's when at 28 minutes, 24 seconds, Phyllis is standing in the doorway and she's
然后有一个我非常喜欢的场景，达里尔走过会议室。他说，嘿，当你们开完会后，休息室里有个派对。但克雷格说的方式，因为克雷格说，嘿，伙计们，当你们开完会后，就像他不知道该怎么称呼它。他们在做什么？会议？你们应该来休息室，因为我们正在举办一个真正的派对。我喜欢这个。就在28分24秒，菲利斯站在门口，她
sort of gazing at the other party and then Ryan comes to get his jacket. And she's like, are you cold? That'll help. Is it cold in there? You know what? That was an improv. That was not in script. Stop it.
正凝视着另一个派对，然后瑞安来拿他的夹克。她说，你冷吗？那会有帮助的。里面冷吗？你知道吗？那是即兴表演。剧本里没有。别说了。
Stop it. Yes. Which part? The final line? It was scripted that Ryan would come and get his jacket. And that Phyllis just says something like, how is it in there? And then he's like, huh? And that was the end of the scene. And then he walks away. So Phyllis being like, maybe that'll help. Is it cold in there? That was Phyllis being like, maybe that'll help. Is it cold in there? That was Phyllis.
别说了。是的。哪一部分？最后一句台词？剧本里写的是瑞安会来拿他的夹克。然后菲利斯只是说了类似“里面怎么样？”的话。然后他说，嗯？那就是场景的结尾。然后他走开了。所以菲利斯说“也许那会有帮助。里面冷吗？”那是菲利斯在说“也许那会有帮助。里面冷吗？”那是菲利斯。
Well, her maybe that would help. Like, about had me fall out of the chair. Her runner is just absolutely one of my favorites in this whole episode. So now the guys return from Benihana. And they have brought waitresses with them. So we covered a little bit of the Benihana waitress storyline with Jen.
好吧，她的“也许那会有帮助”差点让我从椅子上掉下来。她的这个梗绝对是我在这一整集里最喜欢的之一。现在男人们从贝尼哈纳回来了。他们带了服务员回来。我们和珍讨论了一点贝尼哈纳服务员的故事线。
But we did not really talk about this, and we got a lot of fan questions from Emma Bloom, Kelsey Kay, Kayla Bass, Abby Roll, Tinesa Lee, Samantha Mundin, and many others want to know, why do the actresses playing the Benihana waitresses change when Michael and Andy bring them back to the office. Is that supposed to feed into the ongoing joke that Michael and Andy can't tell them apart?
但我们并没有真正谈论这个，我们收到了很多粉丝提问，来自艾玛·布鲁姆、凯尔西·凯、凯拉·巴斯、艾比·罗尔、蒂内萨·李、萨曼莎·蒙丁，还有许多其他人想知道，为什么迈克尔和安迪把贝尼哈纳服务员带回办公室时，扮演她们的女演员换人了？这是为了呼应迈克尔和安迪分不清她们的那个持续不断的笑话吗？
So no. The idea here was simply that Michael and Andy couldn't land the original waitresses that they'd been flirting with all night, and then they managed to get these two younger, kind of more naive waitresses to come back with them to the office. And in the script, it says Michael and Andy walk in not with Cindy and her hot friend, but with two other 20 to 25 year old Asian American waitresses. So the idea was that these two older sophisticated women would never go back to a party. But these two younger gals, college age gals would be like, Oh, yeah, like free drinks. We'll go for care. It's like they're more up
不是。这里的想法很简单，迈克尔和安迪没能追到他们整晚调情的那些原始服务员，然后他们设法让这两个更年轻、更天真一点的服务员跟他们回到了办公室。在剧本里，写的是迈克尔和安迪进来的不是辛迪和她那个火辣的朋友，而是另外两个20到25岁的亚裔美国服务员。所以想法是，这两个年长、世故的女性永远不会去参加派对。但这两个年轻的女孩，大学年纪的女孩会觉得，哦，太好了，免费饮料。我们会去。就像她们更
for it. Yeah, free drinks. And Michael's like, and I have a present for you. It's a bicycle. Yes. And she's thrilled. She's like, I love it. Yeah. Well, I have a background catch. At 29 minutes, when they walk into the office, the girls have on a lot of makeup. And then at 29 minutes, 12 seconds later, no makeup.
乐意去。是的，免费饮料。迈克尔说，我有个礼物给你。是一辆自行车。是的。她很激动。她说，我喜欢它。是的。好吧，我有一个背景发现。在29分钟，当她们走进办公室时，女孩们化了很浓的妆。然后在29分12秒后，没化妆了。
What happened? Well, Angela, a lot of other people notice this as well. Sonia Maria Raposa wrote in with a theory. Oh, she thinks that they appear with makeup at first because that's how Michael perceives them to be because he's drunk and then they appear with no makeup because that's what they truly look like. It's not the case. Jen did a little bit of a deep dive and she actually found an interview that her and Greg did on an office panel about this exact thing. And she said basically it was a continuity error.
发生了什么？好吧，安吉拉，很多人也注意到了这一点。索尼娅·玛丽亚·拉波萨写信提出了一个理论。哦，她认为她们起初化了妆是因为迈克尔喝醉了，所以他眼中的她们是那样的，然后她们看起来没化妆是因为那是她们真实的样子。事实并非如此。珍做了一些深入研究，她实际上找到了她和格雷格在一个关于这件事的办公室座谈会上做的一次采访。她说基本上这是一个连续性错误。
Yeah, exactly. She was telling us that the first day that they worked, they put makeup on them. Then they watched the dailies and they were like, well, wait, that doesn't really track for who they are in the show as their characters, these younger college girls. And you know, they're they shouldn't look that sophisticated. So the next time they worked, they toned down, didn't have them have makeup on. So it was as simple as that. They really wanted to drive home this idea that these were college girls. To kind of further emphasize how ridiculous Michael's infatuation and belief that he's
是的，没错。她告诉我们，她们工作的第一天，化妆师给她们化了妆。然后他们看了样片，他们觉得，等等，这对于她们在剧中的角色——这些年轻的大学生——来说不太合适。你知道，她们不应该看起来那么世故。所以她们下次工作时，他们调低了妆容，没让她们化妆。所以事情就是这么简单。他们真的想强调这些是大学生女孩的想法。为了进一步强调迈克尔的迷恋以及他相信自己
found his true love is. Yeah, and Michael now starts going around the office and introducing Nikki as his new girlfriend. Everyone is like, girlfriend? Huh, really? Well, they realize pretty quickly that Angela's party is super lame. And as they leave,
找到了真爱是多么荒谬。是的，迈克尔现在开始在办公室里走来走去，介绍妮基是他的新女朋友。每个人都说，女朋友？哈，真的吗？好吧，他们很快意识到安吉拉的派对非常无聊。当他们离开时，
Nikki takes one of Angela's decorations, and Angela is ticked off. And she insults her with the Hello Kitty backpack line. It's just a horrible thing to say. Nikki takes one of Angela's decorations, and Angela is ticked off. And she insults her with the Hello Kitty backpack line. It's just a horrible thing to say. And Michael wants to get Nikki away from Angela as soon as possible. So he takes her to the really fun party in the break room. We have Kevin singing karaoke.
妮基拿走了安吉拉的一个装饰品，安吉拉很生气。她用“Hello Kitty背包”那句台词侮辱了她。那真是一句可怕的话。妮基拿走了安吉拉的一个装饰品，安吉拉很生气。她用“Hello Kitty背包”那句台词侮辱了她。那真是一句可怕的话。迈克尔想尽快把妮基从安吉拉身边带走。所以他带她去了休息室那个非常有趣的派对。我们有凯文唱卡拉OK。
Yeah, go to 31 minutes 14 seconds and please watch Ryan it is the most animated I've ever seen him he's like swaying back and forth singing like you gotta know he's like so into it I'm like what's happening Ryan is he drunk too? Well I did have a fan question from this scene okay from Sasha Lara who wants to, does Craig Robinson play the keyboard in real life? Oh, Sasha, yes, he does. He definitely does. Oh, he's phenomenal.
是的，去31分14秒，请看瑞安，这是我见过他最活跃的样子，他前后摇摆，唱着歌，你一定要知道，他太投入了，我心想发生了什么？瑞安也喝醉了吗？好吧，我确实有一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问，好的，来自萨莎·拉拉，她想问，克雷格·罗宾逊在现实生活中会弹键盘吗？哦，萨莎，是的，他会。他绝对会。哦，他太棒了。
Are you kidding? He's amazing. And in those scenes on the show, when Craig would get out the keyboard, it really did turn into a party. Like that was really fun to shoot. Angela, I'm sorry that you weren't in there, but we were having an amazing time. And between takes, Craig would play and we would sing and Kate would sing show tunes. And I mean, it was like, it was exactly as
你在开玩笑吗？他太神奇了。在剧中的那些场景里，当克雷格拿出键盘时，它真的变成了一个派对。那真的很有趣。安吉拉，很抱歉你没在里面，但我们玩得很开心。在拍摄间隙，克雷格会弹奏，我们会唱歌，凯特会唱音乐剧。我是说，就像
much fun as you would imagine it would be. I'm bummed I wasn't in that scene to be able to hang out with you guys like that. But I cherish the times we were all in the conference room. And if Craig for, you know, in the latter years, he was in the main office bullpen and he and Kate would start singing and Ed, I have found a video on my phone. Oh, my God, Jenna, it's us in the conference room. And they just start making up a song and like oh and everyone is singing
你想象中一样有趣。我很遗憾我没在那个场景里，没能和你们那样玩。但我珍惜我们都在会议室里的时光。如果克雷格，你知道，在后来的几年里，他在主办公室的办公区，他和凯特会开始唱歌，埃德，我在手机里找到了一段视频。哦，天哪，珍娜，是我们坐在会议室里。他们就开始编一首歌，哦，每个人都在唱，
and it's so great I love it those are some of my favorite memories I'll text you the video lady should we go back to your super sad party no yes Angela's having a horrible day but a big thing happens here which is that Dwight holds Angela's hand. I know. It's like a very, very small moment. She's holding her boombox in her lap, and they hold hands. Well, this is when then Karen enters and announces that Dwight won the raffle, which of course is like a super passive aggressive thing to try to lure Dwight into the fun of their party. And as Dwight is excitedly opening
太棒了，我喜欢。那些是我最美好的回忆。我会把视频发给你，女士。我们应该回到你那个超级悲伤的派对吗？不，是的，安吉拉度过了糟糕的一天，但这里发生了一件大事，那就是德怀特握住了安吉拉的手。我知道。那是一个非常、非常小的时刻。她把音箱放在膝盖上，他们握住了手。好吧，就在这时，凯伦进来了，宣布德怀特赢得了抽奖，这当然是一种超级被动攻击的方式，试图引诱德怀特进入她们派对的乐趣中。当德怀特兴奋地打开
the gift, Pam kind of clocks Angela's sadness and pulls Karen aside and says, I feel kind of bad for Angela. Hold up. Did Dwight really not win the raffle? No, lady. We just did that to try to lure him to our party. This whole time I- I mean, when did he to try to lure him to our party. This whole time. I mean, when did he have time to enter the raffle? I don't know, but this whole time I thought he won the raffle. I was like, oh my God, Dwight won the raffle.
礼物时，帕姆注意到了安吉拉的悲伤，把凯伦拉到一边说，我觉得安吉拉有点可怜。等等。德怀特真的没赢抽奖吗？不，女士。我们只是为了试图引诱他来我们的派对才那样做的。这一直以来我——我是说，他什么时候有时间参加抽奖的？我不知道，但这一直以来我以为他赢了抽奖。我心想，哦，天哪，德怀特赢了抽奖。
I mean, I always took it to be like another, like how we lured Kevin away from your party. This is how we were going to lure Dwight away by by coming into your party and trying to poach him. Oh my God, mean girls. Here I am, all naive, thinking like, way to go, Dwight. I mean, I don't think he won the raffle. That was my take on it was that it was a little bit of a mean girls moment on Pam and Karen's part. But you get Karen to come around,
我是说，我一直认为这就像我们如何把凯文从你的派对上引诱走一样。这就是我们打算通过进入你的派对并试图挖走他来引诱德怀特的方式。哦，天哪，贱女孩。我在这里，如此天真，心想，干得好，德怀特。我是说，我不认为他赢了抽奖。我的看法是，这是帕姆和凯伦那边的“贱女孩”时刻。但你让凯伦回心转意了，
and now you guys try to make amends. We do. And by the way, I mean, we may be passive aggressively, let Dwight win the raffle, but you stole our power cord and hid it in a plant. I know. I was about to say you guys faked a raffle and I'm shocked by that. How could you? But I full on stole the cable and hid it in a plant. Yes, you sabotaged our karaoke machine. Okay, so now the parties have merged and the karaoke machine has its cord. And we open with Andy and Michael singing Your Body is a Wonderland. Michael is not sure which waitress is his girlfriend here,
现在你们试图弥补。我们确实弥补了。顺便说一下，我是说，我们可能被动攻击地让德怀特赢了抽奖，但你偷了我们的电源线并把它藏在植物里。我知道。我正要说你们假装抽奖，我对此感到震惊。你怎么能这样？但我完全偷了电缆并把它藏在植物里。是的，你破坏了我们的卡拉OK机。好了，现在派对合并了，卡拉OK机也有了线。我们以安迪和迈克尔唱《Your Body is a Wonderland》开场。迈克尔不确定哪个服务员是他的女朋友，
so he's singing to both of them. So we talked a little bit with Jen about all the different songs that people sing for karaoke, but we did not touch on this one, and I have some really good trivia about it. Let's hear it. So we reached out to John Mayer to ask him if we could use his song, Your Body is a Wonderland.
所以他对着她们两个唱。所以我们和珍讨论了一点人们唱卡拉OK时唱的各种歌曲，但我们没有提到这一首，我有一些关于它的非常好的花絮。让我们听听。所以我们联系了约翰·梅尔，问我们是否可以使用他的歌《Your Body is a Wonderland》。
And it was actually BJ Novak who reached out to him because BJ knew him. Knows him. They're pals. He reached out to him and he was like, can we use this? And at first, John Mayer was like, I don't think so. What? He told his friend, uh-uh, not happening?
实际上是BJ·诺瓦克联系他的，因为BJ认识他。认识他。他们是好朋友。他联系了他，说，我们可以用这个吗？起初，约翰·梅尔说，我不这么认为。什么？他告诉他的朋友，呃-呃，不可能？
He was like, I don't think so. And he actually wrote about this on his blog. He was like, one of my favorite shows on television, The Office wanted to use my song, Your Body is a Wonderland, in a scene for their Christmas episode. And he was like, now, I'm not making apologies for my work, but it's safe to say I don't get asked to use Wonderland for strongman competitions and documentaries about aircraft carriers. I usually get asked so that people can goof on it. So I initially turned down the request. But after thinking about it, I decided to go for it, but with one stipulation.
他说，我不这么认为。他实际上在他的博客上写了这件事。他说，我最喜欢的电视节目之一《办公室》想在他们的圣诞特辑场景中使用我的歌《Your Body is a Wonderland》。他说，现在，我不是为我的作品辩解，但可以肯定的是，我不会被要求在强人比赛和关于航空母舰的纪录片中使用《Wonderland》。我通常被要求使用它，这样人们就可以拿它开玩笑。所以我最初拒绝了这个请求。但在考虑之后，我决定同意，但有一个条件。
What was it? He wrote, I want a Dundee. He wrote, I want a Dundee. Ah! Ah! So BJ presented him with a Dundee for Tallest Music Dude. He is very tall. He's very tall. And then he agreed to let us use the song.
是什么？他写道，我想要一个邓迪奖。他写道，我想要一个邓迪奖。啊！啊！所以BJ送给他一个“最高音乐男”的邓迪奖。他很高。他很高。然后他同意让我们使用这首歌。
Well, look, I get it. Andy and Michael are being total idiots in this episode. And so do you want your song to be the song the two idiots picked, right? Right. But he agreed. And Angela, we have a very fun story about John Mayer. We danced at the walk hard premiere party with John Mayer and you were very pregnant. Look, this is like true BFF friendship because I did not feel like being in a dress or in any kind of fancy shoes. But this was a big premiere for you and I was so excited to celebrate it.
好吧，看，我明白了。安迪和迈克尔在这一集里是彻头彻尾的白痴。所以你想让你的歌成为那两个白痴选的歌吗，对吧？对。但他同意了。而且安吉拉，我们有一个关于约翰·梅尔的非常有趣的故事。我们在《永不止步》的首映派对上和约翰·梅尔跳过舞，当时你怀孕了。看，这就像真正的闺蜜友谊，因为我不想穿裙子或任何花哨的鞋子。但这对你来说是一场盛大的首映式，我很高兴能庆祝它。
or in any kind of fancy shoes. But this was a big premiere for you, and I was so excited to celebrate it. And then, of course, because you and I have to, we had to dance. Listen, I left the after party before 10 PM. I was like, I'm out. But I was going to have one dance with my best friend at her big movie premiere. And John Mayer was on the dance floor.
或者任何花哨的鞋子。但这对你来说是一场盛大的首映式，我很高兴能庆祝它。然后，当然，因为你和我必须这样做，我们不得不跳舞。听着，我在晚上10点前就离开了派对。我心想，我走了。但我打算在好朋友的盛大电影首映式上和她跳一支舞。约翰·梅尔当时在舞池里。
And he was dancing with someone. And I'll never forget, he turned around. And I'm sure he was really surprised to see a huge pregnant woman, like directly behind him. And he was like, oh my gosh. He goes, you're so beautiful. And then he touched my belly and he said, blessings, blessings. I will never forget it.
他正在和某人跳舞。我永远不会忘记，他转过身来。我相信他看到一个巨大的孕妇直接站在他身后一定很惊讶。他说，哦，天哪。他说，你太美了。然后他摸了摸我的肚子说，祝福，祝福。我永远不会忘记。
My belly was blessed by John Mayer. And John, thank you from us for letting us use your song. Yeah. And he said he still has his Dundee, by the way. He still has it. He better still have his Dundee. I have both of mine. I have both of mine.
我的肚子得到了约翰·梅尔的祝福。约翰，谢谢你让我们使用你的歌。是的。顺便说一下，他说他仍然留着他的邓迪奖。他仍然留着它。他最好还留着他的邓迪奖。我有我的两个。我有我的两个。
So now we have the scene where Michael is over with Roy and Kevin, and he's kind of trying to brag about his new girlfriend, but it's very clear that he doesn't know which one is Nikki. Right. Kevin and Roy are like, you don't know? You should know. Michael, you should know. This leads Michael to really spin out. He needs to figure out which woman is his girlfriend. So he goes into the kitchen and he does this whole elaborate bit where he's like, where's my girlfriend? Where is she? Is she in the refrigerator? And it's this such this
所以现在我们到了迈克尔和罗伊、凯文在一起的场景，他试图吹嘘他的新女朋友，但很明显他不知道哪一个是妮基。对。凯文和罗伊说，你不知道？你应该知道。迈克尔，你应该知道。这导致迈克尔真的失控了。他需要弄清楚哪个女人是他的女朋友。所以他走进厨房，做了这一整套精心设计的动作，他说，我的女朋友在哪里？她在哪里？她在冰箱里吗？这真是
awkward moment where finally Nikki says, Michael, you know where I am. I'm right here. So then when Michael goes in for a hug, he takes out a pen and he marks Nikki's arm, because this is now how he's going to be able to determine which one of these women is his girlfriend. And Angela, this moment really made me cringe.
尴尬的时刻，最后妮基说，迈克尔，你知道我在哪。我就在这儿。所以当迈克尔走过去拥抱时，他拿出一支笔，在妮基的手臂上做了标记，因为这就是他现在能够确定这些女人中哪一个是他的女朋友的方法。安吉拉，这一刻真的让我感到尴尬。
Yeah, it made me cringe too. I just don't think the storyline would have been written today. Yeah, I don't think so either. All right, well, let's get back to the party. It's going really well. Everyone's having a better time. Karen and Jem exchange Bridget Jones' diary. And Jen told us a story about that. Yes, and Pam gives Toby a robe. Where she got it, I don't know. Maybe it's her robe. That was a fan theory that Pam gives Toby her robe.
是的，我也感到尴尬。我只是觉得这个故事线在今天不会被写出来。是的，我也不这么认为。好了，让我们回到派对上。进行得很顺利。每个人都玩得更开心了。凯伦和吉姆交换了《布里吉特·琼斯的日记》。珍告诉了我们一个关于那个的故事。是的，帕姆给了托比一件长袍。她从哪弄来的，我不知道。也许是她的长袍。这是一个粉丝理论，帕姆给了托比她的长袍。
I like that. Yeah. And that's when the waitresses decide to leave, though. She's like, you know what? This party kind of sucks, and we're going to take off. And Michael's like, no, don't go, don't go. She's like, I'm gonna go. And that's when he invites her on a trip to Sandals Jamaica. It's all inclusive. He is determined to get someone to go on this trip. That is the third person in one day he is asked to go. He asked Carol, he asked Pam, and now he's asked Nikki, the waitress.
我喜欢这个。是的。就在这时，服务员决定离开。她说，你知道吗？这个派对有点烂，我们要走了。迈克尔说，不，别走，别走。她说，我要走了。就在这时，他邀请她去牙买加的桑达尔斯度假村旅行。全包式的。他决心要找个人去参加这次旅行。这是他一天之内邀请的第三个人。他邀请了卡罗尔，他邀请了帕姆，现在他邀请了服务员妮基。
Yeah, but she's like, no, I think I'm just going to take my bike and get out of here. Get out of your lame party. I'm sorry. I really love that she takes the bike. Oh, I do too. She's like, I have this bike at least. Yeah. So Michael is devastated and he's on the couch with Jim and Michael is really mopey. He's like, she was the one.
是的，但她说，不，我想我还是骑上我的自行车离开这里吧。离开你那烂派对。抱歉。我真的很喜欢她骑走自行车。哦，我也喜欢。她说，至少我有这辆自行车。是的。所以迈克尔崩溃了，他和吉姆坐在沙发上，迈克尔真的很沮丧。他说，她就是那个人。
She was my true love and she's gone. And Jim is like, you barely knew her. You knew her for three hours. She's not the one. She was a rebound. And Michael's like, Oh my God, a rebound! And Jim's like, yeah. And he goes on to say, which don't get me wrong, can be a great distraction. But when it's over, you're left thinking about the girl you really like, the one
她是我的真爱，她走了。吉姆说，你根本不了解她。你认识她才三个小时。她不是那个人。她只是个替代品。迈克尔说，哦，天哪，替代品！吉姆说，是的。他接着说，别误会，这可能是一种很好的消遣。但当它结束时，你会想到你真正喜欢的那个女孩，那个
who broke your heart. And Jim is, I mean we know who Jim's talking about in that moment. He's talking about him and Pam. And he's basically saying, Karen's a rebound, just like Nikki was a rebound. But all Michael hears is that he's had a rebound and he's super excited. Yeah. But Jim, we hear you.
伤了你心的女孩。吉姆是——我是说我们知道吉姆在那一刻在说谁。他在说他和帕姆。他基本上是在说，凯伦是个替代品，就像妮基是个替代品一样。但迈克尔听到的只是他有了一个替代品，他超级兴奋。是的。但吉姆，我们听到了。
We hear you, Jim. We hear you. You love Pam. We hear you. Now, Angela, we need to discuss Little Drummer Boy. Okay. We had a fan question from Manda Gervais. Hey.
我们听到了，吉姆。我们听到了，吉姆。你爱帕姆。我们听到了。现在，安吉拉，我们需要讨论《小鼓手男孩》。好的。我们有一个来自曼达·杰维斯的粉丝提问。嘿。
Hey. Spelled differently than Ricky Gervais, but she wants to know, how was it decided that Dwight should hold the microphone for Angela? I found this choice really interesting because they don't want to look like they're dating, but this was kind of the first impression that they gave of interacting in a personal way in front of the entire office. Well, here's my story. I was terrified to sing this song in front of everyone. I do not like singing in front of people. I just am not comfortable singing in front of people.
嘿。拼写和瑞奇·杰维斯不同，但她想知道，德怀特应该为安吉拉拿麦克风是怎么决定的？我觉得这个选择非常有趣，因为他们不想看起来像是在约会，但这算是他们在整个办公室面前以个人方式互动的第一个印象。好吧，这是我的故事。我当时很害怕在大家面前唱这首歌。我不喜欢在别人面前唱歌。我只是不习惯在别人面前唱歌。
It's kind of crazy to my whole family because I will do improv, I'll do standup, I'll do crazy sketch comedy, I'll be all these weird characters. I have no fear ever getting up on stage. But if you want me to sing in front of people, it's like I shut down. Like my brain computer is like, I can't do it. And there's been a few times in my career when I've had to do this. And this was the first time and I was terrified. And I'll never forget, I went up to Harold Ramis, who you guys,
这对我的整个家庭来说有点疯狂，因为我会做即兴表演，我会做单口相声，我会做疯狂的小品喜剧，我会扮演所有这些奇怪的角色。我从来不怕上台。但如果你想让我在别人面前唱歌，我就像关机了一样。就像我的大脑电脑说，我做不到。我的职业生涯中有几次不得不这样做。这是第一次，我吓坏了。我永远不会忘记，我走到哈罗德·雷米斯面前，你们知道，
you know, we've said he was just a teddy bear. And I went up to him and I was like, here's the thing, Harold. I can't do it. I can't do it. I really just can't sing in front of people. And I can't do it. Really calmly put his hand on my back and looked at me and said, but you will.
我们说过他就像个泰迪熊。我走到他面前说，事情是这样的，哈罗德。我做不到。我做不到。我真的就是不能在别人面前唱歌。我做不到。他非常冷静地把手放在我的背上，看着我说，但你会的。
Oh, I was like, oh God, oh no, I'm doing it. I am doing it. But Angela, I looked in the script and this bit of Dwight holding the microphone is not in the script. So how did that happen? I shared with Rain how scared I was. You know, we did a take or two where the microphone was on a stand, you know, and I'm standing holding my hands like in this very sort of
哦，我心想，哦天哪，哦不，我要做了。我要做了。但安吉拉，我在剧本里查过了，德怀特拿麦克风这一段不在剧本里。那是怎么发生的？我告诉了雷恩我有多害怕。你知道，我们拍了一两次，麦克风在支架上，你知道，我站着，双手像这样，以一种非常
like I don't know, I'm clutching my hands and proper very prim and proper clutching my hands in front of my chest. This was an idea that Jen had, you know? And so I'm standing like this, because she was saying that she thought I should look like I'm in a very serious church choir stance or something, you know? So I'm standing like that. And you guys, I was so nervous.
像——我不知道，我紧紧抓住双手，非常端庄，双手在胸前紧紧抓住。这是珍的一个主意，你知道吗？所以我像这样站着，因为她说她认为我应该看起来像是在非常严肃的教堂唱诗班里站着之类的，你知道吗？所以我那样站着。伙计们，我太紧张了。
I was digging my fingernails into the skin of my other hand. I had marks on my hands where I was just like, like death gripping myself. And after the first take, I showed Rain my hands. I was like, I am so, look what I'm doing. I'm so nervous. And Rain, you know, listen,
我把指甲掐进另一只手的皮肤里。我的手上留下了印记，我当时就像是——像是死死地抓着自己。拍完第一条后，我给雷恩看了我的手。我说，我太——看我在做什么。我太紧张了。雷恩，你知道，听着，
he just came through for me, you guys. Just came through for me. I was having a hard time. Even though I know the song, I was so nervous and everyone was through for me. I was having a hard time, even though I know the song. I was so nervous and everyone was looking at me. I was having a hard time staying on beat. And he dropped, he took the microphone, he improvised this. He took the microphone, he dropped to his knee
他真的帮了我，伙计们。真的帮了我。我当时很难受。即使我知道这首歌，我也太紧张了，每个人都在——帮了我，伙计们。我当时很难受，即使我知道这首歌。我太紧张了，每个人都在看着我。我很难保持节奏。他放下，他拿过麦克风，他即兴发挥了这一点。他拿过麦克风，他跪下，
and to help me like find the song, he's just started going, brr-rum-pa-pa-pum, brr-rum-pa-pa-pum, brr-rum-pa-pa-pum. And all of a sudden I wasn't alone. he's just started going, brr-up-up-a-bum, brr-up-up-a-bum, brr-up-up-a-bum. And all of a sudden I wasn't alone. Rain was with me. I mean, Rain is six foot three, so when he's kneeling down, he's almost my height. It was like he was standing side by side with me.
为了帮我找到节奏，他开始唱，哒-哒-哒-哒-哒，哒-哒-哒-哒-哒，哒-哒-哒-哒-哒。突然之间，我不再孤单了。他开始唱，哒-哒-哒-哒-哒，哒-哒-哒-哒-哒，哒-哒-哒-哒-哒。突然之间，我不再孤单了。雷恩和我在一起。我是说，雷恩有六英尺三英寸高，所以当他跪下时，他几乎和我一样高。就像他和我并肩站着一样。
And then I could do it. And you see, if you watch ever so slightly, you see me smile. I'm not smiling because Angela loves Dwight, and she's getting to sing a Christmas song. I'm smiling because Angela Kinsey sees her friend, Rainn Wilson, come through for her. Well, lady, I knew that story, and I was there when it happened.
然后我就能做到了。如果你仔细看，你会看到我笑了。我笑不是因为安吉拉爱德怀特，也不是因为她能唱圣诞歌。我笑是因为安吉拉·金赛看到她的朋友雷恩·威尔逊帮了她。好吧，女士，我知道那个故事，而且我当时就在现场。
And when I watched this scene, I 100% saw that this was a scene between Angela Kinsey and Rainn Wilson. The way he's supporting you and the way you're smiling at him, it is so wonderful. And then it translates into this moment between Dwight and Angela that just enriches that relationship. What a wonderful, wonderful moment. It really is. Anyway, so Rain, thank you so much for coming through for me with your brum-pum-pum-pums and getting me through that scene. Now during all of this, Angela, Oscar and Gil walk into the party. What? And he's like, too soon.
当我看到这个场景时，我百分之百地看出这是安吉拉·金赛和雷恩·威尔逊之间的场景。他支持你的方式和你对他微笑的方式，太美妙了。然后它转化为德怀特和安吉拉之间丰富了那种关系的时刻。多么美妙、美妙的时刻。确实如此。总之，雷恩，非常感谢你用你的“哒-哒-哒”帮我度过了那个场景。现在在这期间，安吉拉，奥斯卡和吉尔走进了派对。什么？他说，太早了。
What brilliant timing though. I mean, that was such a well written moment. Here he is making his return to work. You know, he's bringing his boyfriend. That's it. Oscar is back, right? And then he sees Angela, of all people, singing Little Dr Drummer Boy and he just does a pivot. He's like, nope, not happening. Also during this in the background, we see Roy give Pam a Christmas gift.
不过这时间点真是绝了。我是说，那一刻写得太好了。他回到工作岗位，带着他的男朋友。就是这样。奥斯卡回来了，对吧？然后他看到了安吉拉，偏偏是她，正在唱《小鼓手男孩》，他立刻就转头了。他心想，不，这不可能。另外，在这一幕的背景里，我们看到罗伊给了帕姆一份圣诞礼物。
And we had some people write in to ask, what book did Roy get Pam for Christmas? Was it a really thoughtful gift? This was asked by Juliet Wilson, Donna Miller, Celia Quiggle, Demetri Lizou, Sarah Thorpe, Sarah Fletcher, and Brooke Beagle. A lot of people want to know what the present was. You guys, it was an art book. It was a very thoughtful present. Roy is winning me over.
我们收到了一些听众来信，问罗伊送给帕姆的圣诞礼物是什么书？那是一份非常贴心的礼物吗？这个问题由朱丽叶·威尔逊、唐娜·米勒、西莉亚·奎格尔、德米特里·利祖、莎拉·索普、莎拉·弗莱彻和布鲁克·比格尔提出。很多人都想知道那份礼物是什么。伙计们，那是一本艺术书。那是一份非常贴心的礼物。罗伊正在赢得我的好感。
He wasn't the best boyfriend, fiance, but he's really trying. He's, you know, invested in how to learn how to gift wrap and he's dressing nicer and he's getting in shape and he is like, I'm going to buy you a thoughtful gift. I know. This was intentional. There was a part of the season where I thought Pam might be won over by Roy. And they weren't even sure in the writer's room, right? They hadn't decided. No. No. I had this whole conversation with Greg where I was like, Greg, wouldn't it be like a crazy, crazy thing saying, if the real true love story is Pam and Roy, like what if all this time, Jim is just a device that leads Pam to her real true love of Roy and Roy completely rehabilitates
他以前不是最好的男朋友或未婚夫，但他真的在努力。你知道，他投入精力去学习如何包装礼物，他穿得更体面了，他在健身，他心想，我要给你买一份贴心的礼物。我知道。这是故意的。这一季里有一段时间，我以为帕姆可能会被罗伊打动。编剧室里甚至都不确定，对吧？他们还没决定。不。不。我和格雷格有过一次完整的谈话，我说，格雷格，如果真正的爱情故事是帕姆和罗伊，那不是很疯狂吗？如果一直以来，吉姆只是一个引导帕姆走向她真爱罗伊的工具，而罗伊彻底改过自新，
himself, and that's the love story of the office. It would blow people's minds. And Greg was kind of like, yeah, I hear what you're saying. I also think it's going to be Jim and Pam. But I was like, I'm just saying if we really want to shock people, maybe it's Pam and Roy. And he was like, yeah, I don't know. There are people listening right now and are like, no. So instead of jam fans, there would have been poi fans? Poi fans?
那才是《办公室》的爱情故事。这会让人大吃一惊。格雷格当时的态度是，是的，我听懂你的意思了。但我还是觉得最后会是吉姆和帕姆。但我当时说，我只是说如果我们真的想震惊观众，也许是帕姆和罗伊。他当时说，是啊，我不知道。现在听节目的观众肯定在想，不。所以与其有“Jam”（吉姆和帕姆）粉丝，不如有“Poi”（帕姆和罗伊）粉丝？“Poi”粉丝？
Ram fans. Ram fans. Well, I ultimately, I do believe that it was always going to be Jim and Pam, but we had a break and pause. We had a moment. I think partially because David Denman's performance, we were all a little bit falling in love with Roy right now. Yeah.
“Ram”粉丝。Ram粉丝。好吧，我最终还是相信，结局注定是吉姆和帕姆，但我们经历了一个停顿和间歇。我们有过那一刻。我想部分原因是由于大卫·丹曼的表演，我们当时都对罗伊有点动心了。是的。
Yeah, he did a great job. I think it was such an excellent foil to see Roy step it up. And I think that needed to happen. I think Mindy sort of touched on that when she was a guest. We needed to see Roy really make a go of it. Yeah. Well, I want to say something. What's it with Jim? Jim clocks this through the window and then all of a sudden he's like, hey Pam, I want to
是的，他演得太棒了。我认为看到罗伊做出改变是一个非常出色的衬托。我认为这是必须发生的。明迪在做客时也提到了这一点。我们需要看到罗伊真的去尝试。是的。好吧，我想说点什么。吉姆是怎么回事？吉姆透过窗户看到了这一切，然后突然间他说，嘿，帕姆，我想
do your CIA joke. Oh, do you Jim? You do. Interesting timing. Well, that you're suddenly invested in the CIA joke. Why couldn't he have just left well enough alone? Well, that you're suddenly invested in the CIA joke. Why couldn't he have just left well enough alone? Well, Pam was delighted. It literally saved the day for her. Yeah, she was thrilled. And it's very fun. They decide that they're going to tell Dwight that a helicopter will be picking him up. And he goes up to the roof.
讲你的CIA笑话。哦，是吗，吉姆？你真的要讲。时间点真有趣。好吧，你突然对CIA笑话感兴趣了。为什么他不能顺其自然呢？好吧，你突然对CIA笑话感兴趣了。为什么他不能顺其自然呢？好吧，帕姆很高兴。这简直拯救了她的一天。是的，她非常激动。这很有趣。他们决定告诉德怀特会有直升机来接他。于是他上了屋顶。
And then they play that final prank on him. I know. And then he throws his phone off the roof. Dwight. Amazing. Dwight. Come on, buddy. Well, we can't end this episode without the major cliffhanger, which is that we spot Michael on the phone in his office, inviting someone, a fourth person to Jamaica, and they say yes. And the look on his face, he's like, oh, okay.
然后他们对他进行了最后那场恶作剧。我知道。然后他把手机从屋顶扔了下去。德怀特。太神了。德怀特。拜托，伙计。好吧，我们不能在没有那个重大悬念的情况下结束这一集，那就是我们看到迈克尔在办公室打电话，邀请某人，也就是第四个人去牙买加，而对方答应了。他脸上的表情是，哦，好吧。
Oh my God. But who he has called, we don't know. It will be revealed next week in Back From Vacation. I remember at the table read for this when he read that last line, there was such a buzz in the room. They're like, whoa. We know who it is. We know.
天哪。但他打给谁，我们不知道。下周在《度假归来》中会揭晓。我记得在剧本围读时，当他读到最后那句台词时，房间里引起了一阵骚动。他们都在说，哇。我们知道那是谁。我们知道。
You guys know. And next week we'll talk all about it. Well that's it. We had a Benny Hana Christmas. We had awesome guests. Thank you, Rashida. Thank you, Jen. And thanks you guys for listening.
你们知道。下周我们会详细讨论。好了，就是这样。我们度过了一个《办公室》圣诞节。我们有很棒的嘉宾。谢谢你，拉什达。谢谢你，简。也谢谢你们大家的收听。
Yeah, we'll see you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Creed Bratton. you you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，我们下周见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》第二杯。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里德·布拉顿混音和母带处理。你你你 这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。